happens here yes
members take their seats
tonight
foreign
the chair recognizes the member from
Auburn representative Osborne the moon's
house adjourned from the section
February 2nd 2023. are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
as opposed nay the eyes have it and the
house is adjourned
the house will attend to a Prayer by
house chaplain Reverend Bob Stewart
pastor of Saint Paul's United Methodist
Church in Manchester
thank you
thank you Mr Speaker
good morning and happy Valentine's Day
to all of you may you feel God's love
this day and every day
in Psalm 46 verse 10 we hear these words
be still
and know that I am God
as we Center and settle ourselves in for
the day before us
let us pause to be still for a moment
and connect with God
loving and gracious God
thank you for the opportunity to be
still for just a few brief minutes
to Center and prepare us for the
business and the tasks that are set
before us today
oh God may we follow your lead to be
still
so we can listen to each other before we
speak
when we speak and engage in conversation
with each other
may we do it with respect
for each other
and what we have to offer for the good
of this body
you ask us to be humble servants to
Those whom we represent
that we might be a source of
encouragement a source of help
and a source of Hope for them
we ask for your guidance and Direction
so we can make decisions of integrity
for all the people of this great state
of New Hampshire
God bless each elected representative
present here today
and bless each of the elected leaders
so they can lead effectively as they
move through the business on today's
agenda
today we will all do our best to serve
others humbly
Faithfully and lovingly
oh God I ask and pray with a sincere
heart
that you keep your guiding hand upon
this entire House of Representatives
today
give them the wisdom and courage to walk
humbly with you
and the people they represent
In Praise of You O God
amen
Jay I recognizes the member from
whoopsit representative Thomas Walter
will lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance
foreign
recognizes Betsy and Scott Heron
of the group green heron who will now
sing our national anthem
by the dawn's early light
was so proudly we have
at the twilight's last screaming
who's brought stripes and bright stars
[Music]
were so
gallantly streaming
[Music]
the bones
bursting in
it gave through the night
will still there
away
[Music]
thank you
the house will attend to request for
leaves of absence
Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives foot Linda gold Mason
McGee Merchant Moulton the day important
business Representatives Kerry Cole
Conlin Lloyd Lundgren John McDonald
Nagel proud the day illness in the
family the house will be in order
the day death in the family
representative bolio
these leaves of absence will be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the house
the house will attend to the
introduction of guests Mr Speaker please
welcome Melanie cullinan guest of
Representative Burnham Wendy hunt guest
of Representative colcom Robin Briscoe
guest of Representative alone Karen
Scott guest of Representative amen Luke
riddle guest of Representative Seth King
Tyler Collin Heidi and Theodore husband
and children of Representative Phillips
John lestoka and Orma Thompson guest of
Representative Wendy Thomas Colonel Eric
power United States Air Force retired
guest of Representative Diane power
Sandra and Arthur Herron family of the
singers guests of the house bear with us
in the gallery today
the house will now attend to the consent
calendar
Mr Speaker from the committee on
education House Bill 102 removed by
Representatives papavichi Mueller
cameras McCarter Moffett a bear Terry
Ellen Reed Hines Diane Kelly Christine
Perez
from the committee on Election law House
Bill 482 removed by Representatives Tom
Manion yokella Ellen Reed Santa nastasso
Tony leckis Kathy Kenny tensar papovichi
Mueller Burnham and Granger
from the committee on Election law House
Bill 599 removed by representative Tom
Manion yokella Ellen Reed Santa
nastassos Tony leckis Kathy Kenny tensar
papavichi Mueller Burnham and Granger
from the committee on Judiciary Pascal
340 removed by representative adjutant
Alessandra Murray Ellen Reed Gallagher
saber McWilliams Kaplan Bolton Staub and
Damon and from the committee on state
federal relations and Veterans Affairs
house concurrent resolution 3 removed by
representative contos Manion Gerhard
Ellen Reed Granger Bailey Finney Heinz
wheeler and Potenza
are there any other bills removed from
consent calendar
Senator bondsman moves a consent
calendar with the relevant amendments
that's printed in today's health record
be adopted are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
That was supposed nay the eyes have it
the consent calendar was adopted under
the rules of the house from the
committee on education HB 364 refn it's
referred to a committee on finance the
committee on the executive departments
and administration HB 337fn and HB 519fn
are referred to the committee on finance
in the committee on Health Human
Services and elderly Affairs HB 428 is
referred to the committee on executive
departments and administration and from
the committee on Judiciary H.B 379 FN is
referred to committee on finance
the house will now attend to the regular
calendar
[Music]
committee on finance to which was
referred Senate Bill 1 FNA
an act relative to the closing of this
new youth centers in establishing a
commission to study the public safety of
the secured Youth Development Center and
surrounding communities consider the
same report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendations Bill a lot
of password Amendment are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
those opposed me
your eyes have it and the report is
adopted
and the amendment is adopted
the question is now on the third reading
motion
I make a mistake
the question is on the motion is on the
art of pass as amended all those in
favor say aye those are closed name the
eyes have it
in the committee report is adopted
chair recognizes the clerk Mr Speaker
representative Osborne moves that house
rule 42 be so far suspended as to allow
immediate third reading on Senate Bill 1
relative to the closing of the sununa
youth center Services Center and
establishing a commission to study the
public safety of the secured Youth
Development Center and surrounding
communities
questions on the third with emotion for
Senate bill one
to suspend the rules
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye those opposed nay
the rules are suspended
recognize the clerk Mr Speaker
representative Osborne moves that Senate
bill one relative to the closing of the
Sony Youth Services Center establishing
committee to study the Public Safety and
Security Youth Development Center or
surrounding communities be read by title
only that it be read a third time by
this resolution that its title be the
same as adopted and that it passed at
the prison time
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
I suppose nay
the eyes have it
[Music]
majority of the committee on Health and
Human Services and elderly Affairs which
was referred HB 91 FNA act relative to
privacy obligations of the Department of
Health and Human Services consider the
same report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
majority amendment is zero one four two
h
minority of the committee on Health and
Human Services and elderly Fiesta which
was referred House Bill 91 FNA relative
to privacy obligations of the Department
of Health and Human Services having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution result that is
inexpedient to legislate Senator Seth
came for the minority of the committee
are you ready for the question on on the
uh
Amendment
all those in favor say aye as opposed
nay
the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted
[Music]
question before us now is ought to pass
with Amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay you guys have it and
the report is adopted
the jury the committee on Judiciary to
which was referred House Bill 347 FN Act
established
the previous bill is going as a second
committee to finance
and act establishing a superior court
land use revealed docket having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendations to build out the
password Amendment it's in a bob Lynn
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate Zulu
representative Louise Andres from the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes
question is on the amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye those opposed nay the
eyes have it
the amendment is adopted
now the question before us is ought to
pass with Amendment the chair recognizer
representative Andrus
thank you Mr Speaker good morning
everyone this is a beautiful February
day in everybody making maple syrup in
New Hampshire must be happy
my representative Louise Andrus from
Merrimack County District 5 I serve the
towns of Andover Dan Marie Salisbury
Hill and Webster
I am speaking for the minority of the
Judiciary Committee on House Bill 347 FN
the purpose of this bill is to establish
a land use review Docket in the Superior
Court to expedite the Appeals
of and Land review cases
in 2022
an almost identical Bill House Bill 1389
establishing a superior Courtland use
review docket was presented to the
Judiciary Committee I was on the
committee last year at that time
after a public hearing House Bill 1389
was voted on an executive session by
these Judiciary Committee to send it to
interim study
the full house voted to send the bill to
interim study in June 2022 an interim
study hearing was held
the findings were brought back to the
Judiciary Committee three months ago or
in November 2022.
after discussion in the Judiciary
Committee the vote was not quote not
recommended for future legislation 14 to
5. in the November 18 2022 House
calendar was printed the blog House Bill
1389 FNS establishing a superior court
land use review docket not recommended
for future legislation
representative Rebecca Macbeth for
judiciary
this bill provided for the establishment
of a judge to decide land use cases
within the existing structure of New
Hampshire's Superior Court
while the idea of creating
a specialized court to hear cases
arising from Municipal land use board
decisions
as some Merit the majority of the
committee consider the present status of
the New Hampshire judicial branches
caseload and the lack of the full
complement of 21 the Superior Court
judges sitting on the bench
and determined that this initiative is
not presently appropriate
in addition it was suggested it targeted
judicial training in the state's coil
land use principles May adequately
address the concern which gave this Bill
Gate which rise to this bill
the vote was 14-5
yet in February 23 of this year House
Bill 347 an act to establishing a
superior Courtland reviews docket bill
was just introduced to the Judiciary
Committee for a public hearing at the
executive session the bill was ought to
pass with an amendment 16-4
these are the following things I feel
wrong with this type of Bill
under New Hampshire current law when a
party disagrees with a decision
regarding land use and the PO can be
made to the Superior Court
or to the New Hampshire housing appeals
board
if House Bill 347 is passed
the New Hampshire housing appeals board
stays intact
therefore designating a specific Justice
to a spare area court for a for a court
land use review docket is in my opinion
layering government
according to the testimony of the public
Hearing in January the Superior Court
had the deficit of three and a half
justices
the estimated cost
to add another Justice and the
appropriate people to go along
is approximately five hundred thousand
dollars a year
to me this is an ad added burden to the
taxpayers and the bad money could be
used better elsewhere
one of the appealing parts to passing
House Bill 340 to 7 is generally assumed
it will speed up land use cases
I have heard mentioned that presently
land use cases typically can take three
years or longer to reach a judgment
I ask why
as for example
according to New Hampshire laws chapter
re-hearing and appeal procedures General
Provisions 677
colon 5 priority
any hearing by the Superior Court upon
appeal under RSA 6774 shall be given
priority on the court calendar The
Source 1983 447 colon one effective
January 1st 1984.
another part of the law
appeal and Court review of planning
board decisions section 677-15
the court shall give any hearing under
this section priority on the court
calendar
with these laws already in place why do
we need to designate an additional
Justice in the Superior Court
why are we designating land use
over other significant aspects
that may need priority like for example
criminal cases
New Hampshire is not a home rule state
and therefore local governments obtain
all of their Authority
to act on Planning and Zoning from the
legislature
the legislature has spent years passing
laws regarding zoning
and now by passing House Bill 349 and
adding another layer of government I ask
are we taking away the rights of local
government
if local decisions are an issue
why isn't the legislature requiring
further training for board members in
our local communities
I ask that you vote no on ought to pass
on health Bill 349. thank you
chair recognize representative Lynn
thank you Mr Speaker let me say first I
think it's really important to
understand
this bill makes no absolutely no
substantive changes to the law of land
use in New Hampshire whether this bill
passes or not the substantive law of
land use in New Hampshire remains
exactly the same
to rep to to respond to the previous
speakers when she raised some some very
valid questions I'm sure you may you may
be thinking well what's the answer to
that well here here is one of the
primary answers
the bill that was proposed last year did
not specifically say that we were going
to add a judge to the Superior Court to
handle these kind of cases and so the
argument was a valid argument wait a
minute you're going to be taking those
people are going to be the judges that
are there now if you if you remove one
of them to be the specialized judge for
the land use docket that will be one
less judge to handle all the other uh
cases on the docket this bill Crea
corrects that it specifically provides
that there will be a new judge appointed
to the land you stock it
will be a new Superior Court judge and
that the uh the uh the uh number of
Superior Court judges will be increased
by one
another argument that was made is that
somehow that there's a
a problem with having a specialized
judge to handle just these type of cases
I submit to you that that the contrary
is is in fact the case we have the
experience and in fact this legislation
was modeled after the business court
docket model that that the business
court docket has been in effect for
about 15 years maybe a little bit less
than that it was the Statute of
authorizing it was passed when when John
Lynch was the governor it has been
immensely successful A specialized a
single judge was specially appointed to
the Superior Court to be the business
court judge and fortunately we've had
two great business Court judges the
first one was Judge McNamara who served
for over 10 years until he uh retired
and now we have a judge Anderson who has
replaced him I my
from my knowledge of the legal community
and the business Community everyone
thinks that this is a this has been a a
great benefit business cases have been
moved along much quicker than they used
to be and I think the same thing would
happen here we do have a housing problem
in this state and we have as as I think
even the the prior speaker indicated we
do have backlogs of cases even with the
housing appeals board I this was frankly
a surprise to me but we found out that
even with the housing appeals board and
the cases that they are getting
the docket of of land use appeals cases
in the superior court has not gone down
um so there is and those cases are
complicated they take many of them take
a long time to resolve there's a huge
record often of maps and diagrams and
all kinds of things zoning ordinances
are often very complicated and the
problem now is that when you have when
those are assigned as they are now to
the to the general uh docket of the
judges those judges have a lot of other
things to do including particularly
criminal cases which have to take
priority so what happens is the judge
will work on the case for an hour or two
and then we'll be uh will be off to do
something something else and maybe we'll
get back to it you know a week later or
two weeks later or maybe a month later
which is is one reason that there's such
that there's such a delay in having
those K cases get out if you were
console date the case before one judge
whose only job will be to do the the
land use cases it will
streamline things a great deal as it has
in the business Court context and this
isn't going to be you know the solution
to the housing problem we have in New
Hampshire but it will move the ball
forward significantly I think and it's
for that reason that I asked you uh vote
to approve this Bill thank you Mr
Speaker
representative who was requested a roll
calls that's efficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded
the question before us is the
motion of ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye those opposed nay
your eyes have it the committee report
is adopted and referred to finance
Committee on Public Works to which was
referred House Bill 62 FN
an act relative to adjusting the road
toll having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate instead of John Cloutier for
the committee
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
yeah I haven't committee report is
adopted
okay
committee on science technology and
energy to which was deferred House Bill
3234fn relative to renewable energy
credits this bill comes to us without
recommendation
representative Kaplan is who he uh is
making a motion for ought to pass
representative Bernardi is moving itl
recognized to speak against the auto
pass motion
thank you Mr Speaker
passage of HB 234 would increase costs
to Electric rate payers in New Hampshire
by about 3 million dollars a year
why is this
utilities are required to make
renewable or to purchase renewable
energy credits or to buy alternative
compliance payments
credits or payments
what can they do right now they can buy
credits from from renewable
providers that have done the paperwork
to create the credits
or the law also provides and what this
bill attempts to repeal is they can
sweep credits from those
renewable providers who have not done
the paperwork to create a credit
I'm one of those folks I have a solar
tower in my backyard with 24 panels on
it you may have a rooftop solar system
you don't fill out the paperwork to get
a few dollars worth of credit but the
utilities can sweep those credits claim
them
in in their need to satisfy how many
credits they need to buy or if they
can't find those credits
they have to make alternative compliance
payments
the credits are cheaper
the alternative compliance payments are
more expensive if this bill passes the
ability to sweep those credits is taken
away
New Hampshire will have a rate increase
across the board of about three million
dollars a year
itl list bill
thank you Mr Speaker
recognized representative Kaplan
speaker
the renewable portfolio standard or RPS
is New Hampshire's primary measure
promoting renewable energy its goal is
clear to increase the availability and
use of renewable energy in New Hampshire
to diversify our fuel sources away from
over-reliance on costly dirty fossil
fuels and move us forward to a clean
energy future
a quote from the enabling legislation
RSA 362f renewable energy generation
Technologies can provide fuel diversity
to the state and New England generation
Supply through use of local renewable
fuels and resources that serve to
displace and thereby lower Regional
dependence on fossil fuels this has the
potential to lower and stabilize Future
Energy costs by reducing exposure to
rising and volatile fossil fuel prices
the use of renewable energy Technologies
and fuels can also help to keep energy
and investment dollars in the state to
benefit our own economy in addition
employing low emission forms of such
Technologies can reduce the amount of
greenhouse gases nitrogen oxides and
particulate matter transported into New
Hampshire thereby improving air quality
in public health and mitigating against
the risks of climate change
it is therefore in the public interest
to stimulate investment in low emission
renewable energy generation in New
Hampshire
put it in a nutshell the renewable
portfolio standard was enacted in 2007
to incentivize renewable energy in order
to diversify our sources of electric
power and thereby reduce our Reliance
Independence on fossil fuels and thus
drive down electricity costs for New
Hampshire citizens given the recent
debacle on Energy prices and the
disgraceful spikes in electric rates due
to our continued Reliance on natural gas
it's all the more important to
strengthen the renewable portfolio
programs designed to diversify our
Energy Mix hence this bill
HB 234 is intended
to remove a loophole where the public
distribution utilities and competitive
electricity suppliers in our state are
relieved of their obligation to meet
their annual targets enacted in 2007 by
the general court the renewable
portfolio standard requires our
utilities to purchase a percentage of
their power through renewable energy
credits or wrecks that accrue
automatically to all renewable energy
producers but the loophole in F6 section
2A which is being repealed by this bill
allows the utilities to claim the wrecks
that have not been officially filed
the majority of these belong to
residential solar customers like the
previous speaker who have not filed the
onerous and time-consuming paperwork to
receive the official Rec certificates
which they could then turn around and
sell if they so chose
by not notifying these renewable
producers of their rightful claim to
their wrecks and sweeping up these
unregistered wrecks the utilities and
private companies are claiming millions
of dollars that rightfully belong to
private citizens in effect a private
property taken taking which is a polite
way of saying robbery
the argument in favor of continuing with
this loophole is both disingenuous and
plain wrong on two levels
the proponent s of so-called Rex
sweeping by the utilities will say that
if the utilities are not allowed to take
this free money then they will pay off
the cost of complying with their
obligation the purchase wrecks by
passing along these costs to their
customers in other words raising their
rates
so that's blackmail but even if we
ignore that and Grant that for the sake
of arguments it benefits rate payers to
continue with wreck sweeping if you are
robbing Peter to pay Paul it's still
robbery even if it benefits Paul
as rate payers we will bend to this
blackmail and stand with Paul but it
behooves us as private citizens in a
law-abiding Society to stand with Peter
and say that this practice must end
the other way
this is wrong is the fallacy of
short-term thinking that denies the
effect of incentivizing a more diverse
mix of electric generation sources the
aim of the renewable portfolio standard
and the renewable energy certificates
that are the monetary backbone of the
whole mechanism by allowing the
utilities and generators to make an end
run around compliance the value of the
Rex is cheapened lessening the incentive
and The Leverage power to bring on more
renewable energy production which lowers
demand for more expensive natural gas
and thus lowers rates in the long term
unfortunately our department of energy
seems to fall into this bottleneck and
blinkered point of view by adopting in
their fiscal note accompanying the bill
the point of view of rate payer costs
alone and not assuming the costs and
benefits that would accrue to the entire
state and its people from a
full-throated defense of the renewable
portfolio standard and its aims but as
legislators we must remember that we
represent the state of New Hampshire and
its citizens not the rate payers of New
Hampshire which is a thinly veiled way
of saying the public utilities and
private out-of-state electricity
suppliers of New Hampshire
the fact is that any short-term impact
to rate payers would amount to Pennies
on a monthly bill contrast that with
what we all lose
a faster transition to local renewable
sources which will keep billions of
dollars in our State feeding our economy
in a virtuous cycle of Greater
investment more jobs and cleaner air
the elephant in the room is the climate
emergency we're in that is forcing our
hand on the transition to cleaner
generation
it's an existential threat that demands
to be treated as such the intent of the
New Hampshire renewable portfolio
standards to provide an incentivizing
mechanism for that transition and this
bill HB 234 seeks to strengthen the
mechanism by removing the loophole that
is stealing from New Hampshire citizens
and harming us all so please join me in
voting yes on ought to pass
and I call for a division vote Mr
Speaker
division vote
the division has been requested members
will take your seats
a roll call has been requested who
requested the Roll Call
is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this this will be
a roll call vote
I also come to water
the question before us is the underpass
motion on House Bill 234 it's the roll
call vote chair recognizes
representative votes for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill
would increase electricity costs by 30
million dollars in the next 10 years
and if I also know that this bill seeks
to repeal a law that was passed
specifically to prevent an additional
expense that produces no further benefit
a failure of the cost benefit test
and finally if I know that the original
law has served our well served our state
well over the past Dozen Years and was
opposed by the department of energy
what I now press the red button to
protect our wallets and our paychecks
thank you Mr Speaker
before we get on to the next one uh make
sure everybody turns your voting station
on so you can vote
chair recognizes representative
McWilliams for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill would make utilities actually meet
their renewable portfolio standard
instead of cheating on the backs of New
Hampshire residents who have solar and
have not gone through the arduous
process of registering that solar
which is in effect a taking of private
property and giving to large
out-of-state corporations who don't
really need the money but are getting it
because we've enabled that would I then
vote Yes to close this loophole thank
you Mr Speaker
the question before us is the auto pass
motion on House Bill 234 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
is
[Music]
representative
thank you
the wrong members president had an
opportunity to vote
Gerald recognized the
also recognize the vote
Mission fails not having to attained a
majority
representative Bernardi moves in
expedient to legislate
are you ready for the question
division has been requested for what
reason is a member rise
motion
I moved to table this bill
that is a motion that is in order the
motion before us is the table house bill
234.
the division has been requested
members will take their seats
the motion before us is the lighthouse
Bill 234 on the table
this is
a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
exactly
[Music]
and Roman was President an opportunity
to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
182 voting yay 184 voting a the motion
to lay on the table fails
the question is now we're back to in
expedient to legislate on House Bill
234.
I'm afraid to ask but are you ready for
the question division has been requested
roll call has been requested
who requested a roll call
it is not sufficiently seconded this
will be a division vote
members take your seats
the motion before us
is inexped into legislate on House Bill
234 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll pray it's the
green button if you're opposed you will
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
this
thank you
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend to stay to the vote
for on a vote on the vote is 183 a 184
nay the motion fails for what reason
does a member rise Mr Speaker I'd like
to move on to pass
you have to read
Mr Speaker having voted on the
prevailing side a voted on a side I
would move reconsideration
okay got it okay
thank you
may I renew the motion to lay on the
table at this time
the motion is to lay on the table that
is in order
division has been requested
members will take their seats
the motion before us is to lay House
Bill 234 on the table this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your approach so press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
foreign
[Music]
well mayor was President I had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the vote
346 voting yay 20 voting May the motion
delay on the table passes
committee on science is acknowledging
energy to which was referred House Bill
246 FN relative to uses of monies in the
renewable energy fund
representative
representative not or moves ought to
pass
and moves Amendment
0-2
-0288
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye as
opposed nay
the eyes the eyes have it the amendment
is adopted the motion
the motion is on ought to pass
as amended
chair recognizes representative Munns
thank you Mr Speaker Happy Valentine's
day everyone
for the record my name is representative
Chris muns I serve as one of the four
representatives from Hampton and
Rockingham County District 29.
although I am in speak I'm speaking in
opposition to HB 246 the one thing
everyone on the science technology and
energy committee and I'm sure everyone
in this chamber today agrees on is that
the cost of electricity in New Hampshire
is too high
where we differ is how to address that
challenge both today and for future
Generations
the renewable energy fund was created in
2007 to encourage and support the
development of thermal and electric
power from alternative
non-fossil fuel sources
it is a component of legislation which
also created our state's renewable
portfolio standards
to comply with the renewable portfolio
standards set by Statute electric
service providers purchase renewable
energy certificates from electricity
generators who produce electricity for
renewable sources
electric service providers who cannot
obtain enough renewable energy
certificates for a given compliance year
are required to make alternative
compliance payments it is these
alternative compliance payments that
provide funding for the renewable energy
fund
the committee received testimony from
the New Hampshire Department of energy
that between fiscal year 18 and fiscal
year 22 a total of 20.1 million of
renewable energy funds were invested in
over 4 000 different projects which have
created 177 million dollars of total
economic activity creating jobs and
generating an important and needed
revenues for our Towns County and the
state itself but most importantly it has
helped to diversify our energy sector
and reduce our dependence on fossil
fuels now and in the future
according to the New Hampshire
Department of energy the current
available balance in the renewable
energy fund is 7.8 million dollars the
annual contributions to it are
approximately 4.6 million dollars not
the seven or eight million quoted in the
statement in support of the ought to
pass with Amendment
the proponents of this bill would have
us believe that rebating these funds to
the electric consumer customers in our
state will have a significant impact on
their monthly cost of electricity
according to doe there are 735 700
electric customers in New Hampshire
rebating the funds in the renewable
energy funds to those consumers would
result in at most a one dollar and forty
Cent per month production in average
consumer electricity bills in year one
and 52 cents per month reduction in
years thereafter
those of us who oppose this bill know
that the people of New Hampshire are
smart enough to realize that a rebate of
52 cents or even 1.40 cents per month
will not make a big difference in their
monthly budget and it is extremely
short-sighted when it comes to our
long-term economic future
the people of New Hampshire understand
that to reduce the cost of electricity
in the long term we need to diversify
our energy sources
just like you would diversify your
financial investments and reduce our
independence on fossil fuels such as
Natural Gas
the only way to do that is to continue
to invest in alternative sources of
energy
if we had done that consistently since
the renewable portfolio portfolio
Standards Law was enacted in 2007 we
would be much in a much better position
than we are currently
there are other ways to lessen the
impact of high electricity prices in the
short term
now is exactly not the time however to
cut back on our investments to encourage
and support the development of
alternative energy projects
to do so would be Pennywise and pound
foolish I encourage you to vote no on
the motion of ought to pass with
Amendment thank you very much
Jay I recognizes representative naughter
and I request the division vote Mr
Speaker okay
thank you Mr Speaker Happy Valentine's
Day by the end of all these reports
you're all going to know all about Rex
our ECS RPS acpuc and ref so take notes
I rise in support of house bill 246. to
put it simply it will lower the cost of
electricity by rebating to rate payers
the funds accumulated in the renewable
energy fund ref
to explain right now utilities are
required by law to buy renewable energy
certificates or Rex the wrecks are proof
that energy has been generated from
sources such as solar wind or Hydro
the said energy is sent to the
electrical grid
utilities have to buy their wrecks to
meet their renewable portfolio standard
RPS
the RPS is a mandate that a portion of
generated power must come from sources
such as solarwind or Hydro
if the electrical supplier fails to meet
their RPS requirements by securing the
necessary wrecks they must pay a penalty
called alternative compliance payments
acps
many of the state's competitive
suppliers of electricity have purchased
acps instead of wrecks to avoid
administrative expenses of purchase
purchasing wrecks
alternative compliance payments go into
the renewable energy fund ref those
payments go out as subsidies for energy
projects like solar arrays
once the one such project replaced two
turbines and three valves boosting
capacity by 0.44 megawatts at one
hydroelectric facility
this beat bill would rebate the ref
dollars back to the rate payer employing
the same mechanism that the Public
Utilities Commission uses to rebate the
Reggie or Regional greenhouse gas
initiative auction credits back to rate
payers
it would be uniform across the board on
a per kilowatt basis the these rebates
would lower the cost of electricity for
the state's rate payers
as amended it makes the change temporary
and restored language to ensure that the
department of energy retained funds to
administer the renewable energy fund
ref collects seven to eight million
dollars a year
that is in addition to the over 4
million a year that is rebated from
Reggie
it takes chipping away at this tax here
and that fee there in order to make a
difference in our ever shrinking wallets
if you vote for this bill you will be
voting to lower electricity costs
so I ask you to please press the green
button thank you Mr Speaker and I asked
for a roll call vote
agent of an honor to requests a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
the motion before us is ought to pass is
amended on House Bill 246. this is a
roll call vote care recognize the
representative Corman for parliamentary
inquiry
speaker
if I know that the renewable energy fund
helps to diversify our energy sources
protecting New Hampshire residents from
Wild swings in energy costs
and if I know that renewable energy
reduces the amount of expensive natural
gas used by New Hampshire utility
customers thereby reducing the demand
for natural gas and hence its price
would I press the red button to vote no
thank you Mr Speaker
chair recognize representative Doug
Thomas for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this bill temporarily suspends
the refs during this time of excessive
electricity costs to our suffering rate
payers
now not five years from now and if I
also know that this amendment restores
language to ensure that the department
of energy retained funds to administer
the ref later on
but more importantly further on do if I
know that these taxes all add up ever so
small but they all add up and that this
bill chips away at them bit by bit we
need so that we show our rape here is we
have compassion in their excessive rate
bills
and they all make a difference if I know
all this would I then press the green
button so we can give some relief to our
repairs now not five years from now
thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us on House Bill 246
is ought to pass with Amendment this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed to press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
thank you
[Music]
and while members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will tend to stay to the vote
179 voting yay 186 149
the motion fails
representative munz
moves itl
are you ready for the question
division has been requested
members will take their seats this is a
division vote
the motion before us is inexpective
legislature in house bill 246.
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
the wrong name was president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
let it be known that I did vote to
create a tie
the motion fails
speaker for what reason does a member
rise motion the table
motion at the table is in order the
motion before us is the table house bill
246.
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it
the committee on science technology and
energy to which was we've also be in
order
to which was referred House Bill 418 FN
relative to eliminating the rebates
distributed by the Energy Efficiency
fund this comes before us without
recommendation
representative mums moves ought to pass
on House Bill 418
chair recognizes representative naughter
thank you
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise in opposition to house bill 418.
this bill seeks to eliminate the auction
proceeds rebate to rate payers from the
regional greenhouse gas initiative
which is an energy tax
more commonly known as Reggie
Reggie is a cap and trade scheme in
order to emit carbon dioxide energy
generators are companies that produce
energy are forced to purchase Reggie
credits the cost for this is then passed
on to rate payers however the rebate of
Reggie credits has been in place since
2012 saving rate pairs 120 million to
160 million dollars in the past 10 years
during the hearing the sponsor of this
Bill said that the money does not belong
to the rate payer and that this bill is
a correction
we do not find a 40 million dollar tax
hike to be a correction
New Hampshire utilities have seen their
costs for electricity nearly double due
to Federal policies that inhibit the
production and distribution of natural
gas and oil which are reliable sources
of energy
the price of natural gas dictates the
cost of electricity
political pressures have compounded the
problem
adding costs to our state's already
record high electricity bills hurts
residents and businesses alike
we cannot justify raising the average
rate payers bill by twenty five dollars
to forty five dollars a year
if you vote for your bit this bill your
constituents will know that you voted to
raise their electric bill at a time when
some may be spending 40 percent of their
paychecks on electricity heat and gas
for their car
please press the red button so that a
new motion can be made thank you Mr
Speaker
Geo recognizes representative Harrington
thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
opposition to this bill
I could bore everybody with a lot of
facts about Reggie as I've been involved
in Reggie longer than anybody in the
state other than Bob Scott we were both
appointed by the governor a long time
ago on this but the fact remains is this
is this is a raise your rates of
electricity we've heard it over and over
again well it's we can't control
electric rates as a former puc
commission there's not a lot we can do I
realize that it's a regional market set
in New England and National policies but
we can prevent doing things like this
will directly cause people's rates to go
up
we spend 72 million dollars a year on
Energy Efficiency projects that is all
rate payer funded in New Hampshire
that's more than doubled in the last few
years
we have lots of money for that in fact
sometimes they actually have trouble
spending it all
and everyone keeps telling us that this
salvation is an Energy Efficiency all
you have to do is look to the Future
Massachusetts spends multiple times what
we do on Energy Efficiency that they
take from their rate payers yet their
electric rates are virtually the same as
we are depending on the date when the
contracts assigned sometimes they're a
little lower sometimes they're a little
higher but they're virtually the same so
if Energy Efficiency was this Panacea
that would be in told it is then their
rates should be substantially lower than
ours but they're not remember this does
not reduce any funding for Energy
Efficiency you're still going to pay on
the assistant benefits charge for every
kilowatt hour that you buy you will pay
a fee that goes towards Energy
Efficiency projects so I urge you to
please vote against this bill do not
raise your electric rates on you on your
rate payers
do you recognize representative muns
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise again this time to speak in favor
of adopting HB 418
the Energy Efficiency fund is a
dedicated fund created in 2008 when New
Hampshire joined the regional greenhouse
gas initiative otherwise known as Reggie
Reggie is a regional market for emission
allowances which are sold to electric
power producers at quarterly auctions
New Hampshire's share of emission
allowances is deposited in the Energy
Efficiency fund
one of the best and easiest ways to
reduce our dependence on fossil fuel and
the impact it has in our pocketbooks is
to reduce our demand for electricity
produced using those fuels
if we can lower the demand then we all
benefit with lower prices
that is exactly what the original intent
of the Energy Efficiency fund was
the legislation originally intended that
100 percent of New Hampshire's regi
allowances would be used to support
Energy Efficiency conservation and
demand response programs
however legislation passed in 2013
dictated that only the first dollar per
ton of each allowance sold could be used
to fund the Energy Efficiency fund
since 2013 the remaining proceeds are
rebated to utility rate payers
this bill would reverse that decision
and ensure that all proceeds from the
sale of emission allowances are used to
reduce energy demand
according to the investment of Reggie
proceeds in 2020 report issued in May of
New Hampshire received approximately
18.8 million dollars in Reggie
allowances proceeds during 2020.
2.5 million of that
total were allocated to the Energy
Efficiency fund and invested to install
Energy Efficiency measures in 163
municipal buildings and to weatherize
476 homes
that small investment of 2.5 million
dollars will save over 53
000 megawatts of electricity and will
lower electricity rates by 10.5 million
dollars over the life of those
improvements
that is a return on investment of over
400 percent
the science technology and energy
committee received testimony from the
New Hampshire Department of energy that
New Hampshire's share of Reggie
allowances sales in 2022 was 43 million
dollars
40 million of 40 million was rebated in
short-term savings to customers the
equivalent of about
1.77 per month for the typical
residential customer
none of that 40 million dollars was used
to help reduce the overall demand for
power in our state
had it been invested in projects to
reduce demand similar to those in 2020
the long-term reduction in cust and
consumer bills would be approximately
160 million dollars
and that would only be from one year's
worth of Energy Efficiency fund
Investments
had we not changed the rules in 2013
under which Reggie allowances were
utilized and had instead consistently
invested those funds in projects to
reduce demand there is every reason to
believe that the impact customers are
facing now because of our over-reliance
on natural gas to generate electricity
would be less
all of us know that the cost of
electricity in our state is too high
the people of New Hampshire realize that
when we rely almost exclusively on
natural gas to produce our electricity
we are going to have to pay the price
when demand continues to outstrip supply
they also know that when external events
affect the supply of natural gas
prices will continue to go up unless we
do something to reduce demand
it's time that we here in the people's
house recognize that as well and once
again ensure that 100 of the allowances
New Hampshire receives from Reggie are
used for the purpose they were intended
to support Energy Efficiency
conservation and demand response
programs that will benefit all of us I
urge you to join me in voting yes on the
motion of ought to pass and Mr Speaker I
request a division vote
representative Vose has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
years
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 418.
this is a roll call vote
care recognizes representative votes for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know this bill increases yearly
electricity costs by 40 million dollars
which will result in a 10-year cost of
nearly a half a billion dollars
and if I know we already spend 72
million dollars on Energy Efficiency
today
and that increasing that to 40 million
dollars is an unnecessary expense
what I now press the red motion button
and vote no
on this motion thank you Mr Speaker
I recognize representative Christian for
a parliamentary inquiry
Thank You Cher thank you all for your
patience
if I know that the intention of this
program is to support Energy Efficiency
if I know that Energy Efficiency reduces
demand which lowers prices for everyone
if I know that the cheapest kilowatt
hour is the one that we don't use
and finally if I know that the role of
the state government is to enact
policies to support long-term energy
affordability
and if I know that New Hampshire
families can no longer afford the
Pennywise and pound foolish energy
strategy that we have pursued for the
last decade would I now press the green
button
the motion before us is ought to pass in
House Bill 418 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposed will press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
foreign
[Music]
Gilman
representative Gilman
of all members president an opportunity
to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
183 voting a 185 voting a the motion
fails
for what purpose does a member rise
motion the table
motion to table is in order
motion before us hits the table house
bill 418.
division has been requested
members take their seats
it's experience
a motion before this is a table House
Bill 418 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your opposal press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative Malloy
well remember this president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the vote
186 voting yeah 182 voting a the motion
passes House Bill 418 is laid on the
table
before we get to the next bill
my intention is to stop around 10
minutes or 12.
give you to about 10 minutes of one
so that we can get the senate in here
and go into joint session right about
one o'clock that's when the governor is
going to give his budget address
and then after the budget address which
will probably take 45 minutes to an hour
we will go back into session working on
more bills
committee on science technology and
energy to which those referred House
Bill 576 FNA local enact establishing an
energy conservation program in an energy
conservation project fund establishing
the state Pace Reserve fund
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with Amendment Senator Rebecca
McWilliams for the committee
the amendment is zero one six two H
printed in house record 11 pages 42-43
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it and
the amendment is adopted the motion
before us is ought to pass with
Amendment on House Bill 576. are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
the eyes have it in the emotion the
emotion is adopted and is referred to
the finance committee
the committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred House Bill
630 FN establishing a revolving clean
energy accelerator Fund in the
department of energy this comes to us
without recommendation
representative McWilliams moves ought to
pass
and offers floor Amendment zero four
eight eight h
the chair recognizes representative
Thomas to speak against the amendment
thank you Mr Speaker
um the amendment basically doesn't
change the basic bill that much it's
it's really too big and we're against
the amendment as well we didn't hear it
in public hearing as well
so my speech I'm going to reserve my
speech time for the actual bill itself
but the amendment should not be passed
please vote itl on on the amendment
chair recognizes representative Bank
Williams
by the department of energy to clear up
any concerns or questions about how
funding would happen for administration
of a fund the way this is set up is that
there is a revolving energy fund and
Department of energy may have
administrative fees and costs including
hiring new staff
so the amendment is set up to make sure
that if there are costs the federal
funds that this bucket is created to
receive could be used immediately for
administrative costs for staff for
Department of energy it was a
clarification as part of what came out
during the hearing on the underlying
bill and I think that it's important
that we do pay for administrative costs
through federal funds because the
overall Bill does not cost us anything
as a state the intention of the green
bank is to receive infrastructure
reinvestment act funds for the State of
New Hampshire this is already money that
people from New Hampshire have paid in
taxes to the federal government and they
are coming back to our state
and the intention of this bill is that
department of energy could apply for and
receive the funds in one big bucket and
then direct how the funds will be used
for infrastructure reinvestment here in
New Hampshire you will hear that there
is an opportunity for other
organizations to apply for the funds but
it would be piecemeal as opposed to the
Department of energy and so therefore I
ask that you vote Yes on this amendment
to clarify that if there are
administrative costs in receiving funds
from the FED they are paid for through
that bucket and not by us the state of
New Hampshire thank you Mr Speaker
the question before us is floor
Amendment 0488h
I
I a division has been requested members
will take their seats
the motion before us is floor Amendment
0488h
this is a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
votes for a parliamentary inquiry
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this underlying bill is
really not necessary
and if I also know that this amendment
therefore is also unnecessary
but I press the red button thank you Mr
Speaker
I recognizes representative Mick
Williams for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the amendment to this bill
makes a good bill better and if I also
know that the department of energy
specifically requested the amendment to
this bill and it was done on their
behalf following testimony to make sure
that this would work if we have a bucket
to receive federal funds would I then
vote green to enable receiving federal
funds and accepting the amendment to
make it even cleaner thank you
the motion before us is the floor
Amendment 0488h on House Bill 630.
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed to press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
this is
[Music]
Paul members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
under an 86 voting a 184 voting a the
amendment passes
the question before us now is on
HB 630 as amended the motion is ought to
pass as amended chair recognizes
representative Thomas
thank you Mr Speaker
you know it gives me great pleasure to
finally say that I don't have to say one
word about kilowatt hours Rex Reggie RPS
net metering because they just don't
apply to this bill
the fact is is that this bill is not
needed
we already have mechanisms in place that
can handle this this particular program
you've heard it's a revolving fund they
call it a green Bank fund to receive
federal dollars it comes from the
greenhouse gas reduction fund which has
not been given to us yet it's a
competitive Grant we don't know how much
money we might get we might get none of
the 27 billion that is being offered out
there
uh but I'm sure we'll get some if we ask
for it apply for it appropriately
the department of energy would be the
managing Agency for these funds if they
came in here but from their own
testimony
Doe's own testimony says that they have
mechanisms mechanisms already in place
to receive funds like this having a
revolving Green Bank fund is not a
condition to receive these Federal
monies at all we we don't need it it's
not a condition to get it
so first of all one of the objections or
one of the points a doe made was that
it's uh was that it was not a condition
and that and that they have they on
revolving funds they have Outsourcing
agencies that they go to to handle funds
like this so they're already set up to
do they just have to have the money and
they choose which which one to you know
send to
uh the doe has experience and they're
doing this in a in receiving grants like
this and uh in terms of of uh this
particular Bill we would be setting up
just another revolving fund uh to handle
monies that Doe can already dispense
through through the mechanisms so
finally uh the government has not
released all of the details on this
particular 27 billion dollars like what
are the conditions where the what are
the ramifications if we were to set up a
revolving fund now specifically to
receive these funds Doe's testimony said
that we might be putting conditions or
restrictions or guidelines in there that
might eventually contradict what the
federal government comes out with when
they finally release those those
guidelines those guidelines are not
coming out at any time very soon even
though this bill was passed some time
ago previous examples of fundings that
have been passed particularly say in
2021 some of those guidelines still have
not come out as to how we're going to
handle or receive those so we're not in
a rush and we if we establish something
now we might be putting something into
effect that may contradict the
government later
thank goodness I didn't have to use the
word kilowatt hour on this one here it's
just that we don't need this bill and so
we suggest that we itl thank you Mr
Speaker
gee I recognize representative
McWilliams
May 14th
we are just getting started here in the
house and we're getting into our groove
on voting on bills
this bill
enables us to receive money from the
federal government through the
infrastructure reduction act
reinvestment act
we know that they've earmarked 27
billion with a B dollars and some
portion of that could come to New
Hampshire if we apply for it
this bill creates a bucket to receive
the funds of the Department of energy
the challenge here is that we the New
Hampshire legislature are only in
sessions six months of the year but the
federal government has these rolling
funding opportunities that if you miss
it if we're not in session if we're not
voting if we're not able to do some kind
of emergency legislation
we miss out
and so I would ask you to consider
keeping this bill alive as long as we
can while the FED gets their act
together for the application so that we
can meet in the middle and receive the
funds through the department of energy
through this new green bucket
so that we can have the money when the
application comes out even if we're not
currently in session and so we do not
miss out on that opportunity
let me talk a little bit about a green
Bank
what a green bank will not do is cost
the state money
a green Bank uses zero State funding
and as amended even the administrative
costs the department of energy will be
covered by federal dollars
this bill does Not Duplicate existing
opportunities that already exist it
expands the opportunities
this bill Will Not Duplicate services
offered by commercial banks in this
instance the term Bank revolves to the
revolving fund with the Department of
energy and not a banking Institution
would a green bank will do it will
create a fund to help New Hampshire
projects with challenges in the changing
energy Market
it will provide oversight through the
department of energy to minimize risk
choose priority projects and maximize
these federal dollars for which New
Hampshire will be eligible it will also
attract private sector investment funds
from the inflation reduction act can be
leveraged with private funding to reduce
Financial Risk and overcome Market
barriers
we cannot guarantee that New Hampshire
will get a penny of the potential 27
billion dollars that will become
available for the states unless we have
a mechanism for receiving the funds
we do not know all the parameters now
for administering the monies but let's
be smart let's set it up and create a
bucket to receive the funds and we know
that our chances of maximizing those
monies will be there when the time comes
thank you
the motion before us is the ought to
pass as amended motion on House Bill
630.
a division has been requested
members take their seats
clear
motion before us is
ought to pass as amended on House Bill
630.
care recognizes representative votes for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the department of energy has
many many buckets to receive federal
dollars and does so all the time
if I also know that the fiscal Committee
of the general court meets year round
and is empowered to accept
or reject federal dollars
and lastly if I know that the adopted
Amendment describes such a complicated
process to accept these federal dollars
that it could prove to be more of a
hindrance than a help
what I now press the red button to avoid
the rush to create something that we
really don't need
thank you Mr Speaker
I recognize representative powersol for
a parliamentary inquiry
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that this enabling legislation
uses no State funds but creates a
vehicle to return federal tax dollars to
New Hampshire citizens
and
if I know that the fund can generate
valuable public private Partnerships
and last
if I know
that without a green Bank we are putting
our slice of a 27 billion dollar Federal
Grant in jeopardy
what I now
vote
green and the ultra pass with Amendment
uh
thank you
the motion before us is auto pass as
amended on House Bill 630. this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppose
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
movement
[Music]
representative wolf
okay
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will tender state of the vote
185 to 185 I did not vote
so the motion fails
for what reason does a member rise I
move in expedient to legislate
promotion to inexped into legislate news
proper motion
Mr Speaker
like to make a motion uh stage your
motion motion to table
and there's a higher motion that motion
motion is in proper order who requested
a roll call
representative Barry requests a roll
call was that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
the motion before us is
the table house bill 630.
this is a roll call vote you're in favor
you'll press the green button if your
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
household into state or vote
184 voting a 186 voting a the motion
fails
defeating delicious
ly the question before us now the
pending question is inexpedient to
legislate
are you ready for the question
[Music]
the vision has been requested
all members take their seats
representative Hall requests a roll call
is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
uh the house will be in order
the motion before us is the inexperiod
to legislate on House Bill 630.
this is a roll call vote you're in favor
you'll press a green button if you're
opposer press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
house will tend to say to the vote
187 voting yay 182 voting a the motion
in expedient to legislate passes
for these lunchtime we have three
announcements
staying please stay in your seats until
the announcements are done only take a
couple of minutes and then we'll go into
uh recess until
150.
well 12.50
chair recognizes representative Carol
McGuire
all right this is for your information
you know that we passed the laws many of
the agencies make rules to expand on and
implement the laws that we pass
so happens that there's sometimes
concerned that they're not meeting the
legislative intent
so in order to help stop that each of
you will be receiving one email a week
which lists the rules that are
drafted and out for comment please take
a look at it if you know something about
any of those rules please comment and I
hope that will help
those of us who have to vote on those
rules without being subject matter
experts to make the right decisions
thank you very much
house will be in order
chair recognizes Representative Steven
Smith
the committee on Election law will meet
at noon and lob 306 to exec house bill
453.
Jay I recognize representative hunt
thank you Mr Speaker to the Commerce
member I'm sorry about the confusion the
calendar but we will not meeting this
afternoon after session we'll see you
all tomorrow at 10 o'clock
chair recognize representative Vose
thank you Mr
science technology and energy recessed
two exec sections on Monday for house
bills 208 and House Bill 298 we will
resume those executive sessions on
Thursday the 16th of February at 1 pm
thank you
houses in recess until 12 50.
the house will attend to a resolution
[Music]
Mr Speaker Representatives Osborne and
Wilhelm offer the following resolve that
the House of Representatives notified
The Honorable Senate that it is ready to
meet a joint convention for the purpose
of hearing the budget addressed by his
Excellency Governor Christopher T sununu
the question on the adoption of the
resolution are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
there's opposed nay the eyes haven't the
resolution is adopted
[Music]
representative
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the hospital turned away Senate message
Mr Speaker the Senate is ready to meet
with the honorable House of
Representatives and Joint convention for
the purpose of hearing the budget
addressed by his Excellency the governor
Christopher T sununu
Geo recognizes Sergeant at Arms
Mr Speaker The Honorable Senate
[Applause]
thank you
chair recognize you
I didn't say anything yet Pierre
recognizes his Sergeant at Arms Mr
Speaker president of the Senate The
Honorable Jeb Bradley of Wolfeboro
[Applause]
The Joint convention will come to order
yeah recognizes the Sergeant at Arms
[Music]
[Applause]
joint convention will be attentive to
the budget Address given by governor
sununu
I'm already touching the microphone they
told me not to touch the microphone
well thank you good afternoon I was
going to go with the good morning but I
think we're beyond that and Happy
Valentine's Day I was reminded that
someone said oh you were so smart you
remembered to wear red on Valentine's
Day
complete accident to be honest but I am
out doing Jeb Bradley
so we were trading ideas to not to
forget to go grab some flowers or some
candy or a present or something just to
make all is well at home so hope
everyone is having a good day a good
week I know you guys are busy
um
so obviously Mr Speaker Mr Senate
President honorable members of the House
the Senate uh members of the executive
Council that are joining us the commit
we have a few Commissioners joining us
some students uh joining us today so uh
thank you very much and obviously to our
fellow citizens who are watching online
or streaming or TV I don't even know if
it's on TV but uh it's a budget address
so who isn't riveted to this right
must-see TV so today I am here to
present uh the our my recommended budget
for fiscal years 2024 and 2025 and it's
an exciting opportunity to continue on
our path of economic growth uh the
ideals of personal Liberty that we've
built over the past six years I can say
without a doubt I'm traveling around the
country a lot lately and without a doubt
New Hampshire truly is the Envy of the
nation and the free estate in the Union
of other Governors and individuals will
come up all the time they ask how has
New Hampshire been so successful in
keeping their economy strong even
throughout covet and I explained to him
it's because we don't overly burden our
citizens with taxes and fees and we
ensure businesses can be successful
without unnecessary regulations and
bureaucracy government is not here to
guarantee a solution to your problems
but it is here to pave a pathway of
opportunity Pathways for economic growth
Pathways for Educational Opportunity
Pathways for lower taxes and Pathways
for more personal freedoms
over the last six years we've taken
steps to chart a fiscally responsible
and often a very Innovative course for
our state those principles are all
Guided by the budget
it's a road map for the future and a
blueprint for our continued success
across this country states are facing
budget shortfalls they're facing
deficits when times were good these
states increased taxes they built
expensive new government programs
without long-term strategies and frankly
they spent like crazy but not here in
New Hampshire
unlike Washington DC we balance our
budgets in the 603 just like families do
just like businesses have to unlike
other states we don't raise taxes to
meet our needs we shift resources to
where they're needed the most and unlike
the rest of the country we cut taxes we
increase Investments we work together
and we always find a way Republican and
Democrat always find a way to get the
job done
we do it without a sales tax we do it
without an income tax we do it without
an estate tax we do it without this
millionaires tax and good luck to
Massachusetts on that one we'll see how
that turns out and soon New Hampshire
will completely do away with its
interest and dividends tax as we fully
phase that out
[Applause]
but wait there's more there's more in
this budget I am recommending the
complete elimination of the seven
percent consumer communication Services
tax it is outdated it is regressive and
it is just High time we stopped taxing
people on their phone calls
it actually took me a while to realize
that that's what we were doing we tax
people for making a phone call it's just
it's so regressive
so unlike the fiscal confusion in
Washington this budget is fiscal
fiscally responsible and it's balanced
it ensures a surplus with additional
savings for our rainy day fund it has no
new taxes or fees of any kind it
provides relief to property taxpayers it
sends more cash to schools and cities
and towns it invests in our workers and
for the first time ever we're
recommending a significant adjustment to
the education funding formula to ensure
that we reduce the property tax burden
to our citizens and give kids the
adequacy that they deserve you've heard
me say it before and you'll hear me say
it many times again when it comes to
government there is no greater
responsibility than managing other
people's money it is not our money it's
theirs
families across the state they're the
ones that spend time away from their
loved ones they're the ones that sweat
out their paychecks and they work hard
to earn a living and it's our job
to let them keep as much of their money
as possible and make sure we're being
efficient with that trust
when it comes to our state's finances
times are good we have managed smartly
we've maintained our economic advantages
and we have worked hard to live within
our means as a result we're proposing a
smart and targeted budget that sets us
all up for an even brighter future by
prioritizing people over programs so
one of the big issues
endemic people grew Restless they
started exploring New Opportunities some
many of them quit their jobs they look
for new adventures they tried something
different we saw it all over the country
New Hampshire state government was not
immune from these challenges like many
Industries we continue to face a
significant Workforce shortage right now
our State Workforce vacancy hovers
around 20 percent
this budget will change that today I'm
announcing that this budget includes an
agreement between the state and union
representatives for an across the board
10 percent pay increase to our State
Workforce the single largest increase in
state worker salaries in nearly 50 years
followed by another two percent raise
after that
[Applause]
it's not because of its politicians and
Concord it's because of the commitment
to customer service from our employees
that allows New Hampshire to be
recognized as having America's best
return on taxpayer investment and the
most efficient government in the nation
and to all of our ten thousand state
employees we do say thank you
another area that this budget focuses on
is investments in our long-term future
of course number one our kids you always
got to be sure we're putting the kids
first the foundation of any successful
Community starts with education and
today in New Hampshire a child's zip
code does not define their chance at
success in just the last six years we
made record investments into early
childhood education we signed a full day
kindergarten into law we created career
academies giving high school students
access to an associate's degree at no
cost we created the very successful
education Freedom accounts for
low-income families this budget Builds
on those successes by taking the
opportunity to rebuild the education
funding formula allowing us to both
reduce the property tax burden for towns
across the state and increase base Aid
inadequacy for the first time in history
so how can we possibly spend more money
on public education than ever before yet
still cut taxes and reduce the
obligation from local communities
as we like to say we're Wicked smart
right now the education funding formula
for many of those in this room who have
explored into it I think we can all
agree it is overly complicated it is
fundamentally in balance and it could
and it creates an unspent Surplus every
single year
this proposal first and foremost
simplifies things we start by increasing
both base Aid and the free and reduced
lunch by approximately 25 and 30 percent
respectively just over this biennium
overall New Hampshire schools will see
an additional 200 million dollars over
the next two years and an additional 1
billion over the next 10 years all with
a priority towards school districts that
need Aid the most these Investments
which which flow directly to Local
Schools will help cities and towns
offset their property taxes
the changes proposed will also have the
effect of increasing funding to Charter
Schools and doubling the opportunity to
our very successful education Freedom
accounts
obligation and an opportunity
to give families the ability and the
freedom to chart their own path forward
and let's never forget
that it's not easy
and we have to have the courage to set
education funding on the right path once
and for all critics say that many of our
programs have grown too large to them I
say this when a new door of opportunity
is opened and our citizens are racing
through in record numbers that's not an
out of control system it's the
government finally working that's a
government finally ensuring that the
system works for families and the system
meets the needs of the child not the
other way around
and that's something that we should
always be fighting for
now believe it or not even after some of
these changes are made we still have the
opportunity to invest in significant
School building Aid I'm proposing a 75
million dollar investment taken directly
from the education trust fund Surplus to
get assistance to ensure that our
buildings are as strong and as reliable
as the kids that count on them
so we're also we talk about we're
funding kids at unprecedented levels
huge opportunity there we're building
new classrooms long uh in waiting to get
school building Aid going again in a
significant amount and we also have a
chance to introduce new opportunities
into our curriculum to ensure that our
students have the next generation of
Workforce skills namely computer science
there's absolutely no job of the future
not a single job of the future that will
not rely on computers or computer
science in some form the workforce
demands today already outpace the
available skills and these aren't just
any jobs they are high paying careers
and we can ensure that every one of our
children has the opportunity to capture
those openings I believe that computer
science virtually guarantees that anyone
with those skills will not end up in
poverty and who better to learn language
skills than children it's so much easier
for kids to learn computers and computer
coding than adults so let's be sure
we're giving it to them
I'm proposing New Hampshire's greatest
computer science opportunity in history
five million dollars towards a computer
science initiative that creates a
Statewide credentialing system pays
incentives to hundreds of new computer
science teachers to become certified
within their schools at absolutely no
cost
this budget also doubles down on real
world applications by being the first
state in America to bring it New
Hampshire's first robotics to every
middle and high school classroom in the
state with their new experimental
robotics program it's an exciting new
program that allows students to grow
their skills and prepare their pathway
into the workforce
now I also believe that understanding
our system encourages participation in
our system that's very much the New
Hampshire way it's very much part of our
live for your die spirit
we need to maintain our example for
America with our community-based
approach to government and community
I'm proposing over two million dollars
to develop and update a new
hampshire-based Civics curriculum for
our kids
and finally I think we have an exciting
opportunity to ensure that we're
motivating our kids to be engaged and
reach for the stars not all heroes wear
capes but some wore spacesuits
this week I'm establishing a commission
and this budget will allocate funding
for the design and construction of a
statue of one of New Hampshire's most
revered teachers Krista McAuliffe to be
placed right here on State House grounds
to commemorate her selfless contribution
to the state of New Hampshire and the
world it is long overdue and then
undoubtedly will inspire the Next
Generation
[Applause]
now beyond the classroom there continues
to be a lot of opportunity to address
our pressing needs the demand for mental
health services for adults and children
remains incredibly High not only in New
Hampshire but Across the Nation
that's why this past year the state made
a landmark investment in the Children's
Mental Health Services by purchasing
Hampstead Hospital this budget continues
to support that investment by providing
much needed Financial Resources for its
operation and long-term sustainability
we're investing in juvenile peer-to-peer
grief support services to help students
cope with the loss of loved ones we're
investing two million dollars into
Family Resource Centers to help families
in crisis get the supports that they
need
now not so unsurprisingly the lack of
mental health Workforce continues to be
something that holds us back that's why
this budget provides student debt relief
to encourage our students to choose a
future in these very rewarding fields
and stay in work here in the state of
New Hampshire
and we recently secured another round of
State opioid grants an amazing
opportunity over 50 million dollars over
the next couple of years a testament to
the doorway system that we've built to
ensure the wrap around wrap around rural
access to care and services starting
with prevention treatment and Recovery
are always there for our citizens
additionally we're putting more
resources than ever before into our
recovery friendly workplace initiative
which has not only outpaced its growth
in our state but just last week our team
was presenting to all 50 states across
the country many of which who have
already adopted this program the
recovery-friendly workplace initiative
it's going National it's very exciting
and we in New Hampshire are doubling our
efforts to help ensure that everyone
with this disease has a chance to work
and contribute
now none of these great efforts are
possible without people right it always
comes back to people so we are
acknowledging the countless health care
workers on the front lines but by
proposing an across-the-board Medicaid
rate increase to help recruit and retain
these critical workers
[Applause]
housing crisis we see it on the news
every day last year the invest in h
housing program became the most
transformative in historic housing fund
that the state had ever become a part of
on top of that initial 100 million
dollar Grant we're dedicating an
additional 30 million dollars to invest
in h to help meet those demands and
we're increasing our investments into
the affordable housing fund by 25
million dollars ensuring that we can
construct or at least rehabilitate more
affordable housing for low-income and
moderate income families
[Applause]
when we talk about housing homeless
Mental Health Services access to
treatment and Recovery we cannot forget
our veterans our military service
veterans stood strong for us and we will
continue to be there for them
creation of the first of its kind
veterans campus with housing support
services and respite beds it got
underway this past year in Franklin
and the Investments that we're making in
Workforce in this budget will help
ensure that there are that there are
individuals trained licensed and ready
to assist our veterans on this campus
and then our state's veterans home we've
included a new allocation of 8.4 million
dollars for the Department of military
and veteran services we relied on New
Hampshire's National Guard throughout
the pandemic we saw him every day on TV
and we must now ensure that they have
the resources in place to complete their
missions
smart budgeting and fifth responsibility
comes the opportunity to use State
surplus funds for Capital Investments we
cannot and should not rely on these
one-time funds for long-term programs
that would create huge problems down the
road too many states actually get caught
up in those one-time windfalls and they
create unsustainable government programs
that then must be funded by higher taxes
on their citizens in the future that
kind of buy now buy now pay later
mentality it's just not how we do things
in New Hampshire which means that we
spend one-time revenue on one-time
projects and by budgeting accordingly we
avoid irresponsibility growing the size
of government and burning our taxpayers
with long-term liabilities
so with the numerous one-time
infrastructure Investments that this
budget proposes and that the capital
budget also includes we'll be adding
approximately 180 million dollars to the
rainy day fund by the close of fiscal
year 25. building up our reserves I will
take that
[Applause]
that lies ahead of us as strong as we
are today we're already seeing it
flounder in other parts of the country
and it is critical to build up those
reserves going during good times that
we're currently experiencing to ensure
that any future downturns that may
impact the state are at the smallest
degree possible
and lastly before we close out
I got to get something really
controversial
it's not that controversial but it's
hard right it's a big challenge
this budget continues
continued a message to businesses across
the country that New Hampshire will
remain a hub of innovation and here in
the granite state we listen to and we
work with the businesses that are the
Bedrock of our communities
after years of cutting thousands of
pieces of big government red tape we
continue to find in efficiencies and to
streamline improvements to the office of
professional licensure and certification
we call it oplc
this budget includes Landmark
legislation to Grant Universal license
recognition for the professions in New
Hampshire that require a license if you
have a substantially similar license and
you're in good standing in another state
there's no reason you should not have a
license on day one in New Hampshire
if a small business owner needs a
license to do their job or operate their
business in the current state New
Hampshire will recognize their license
right here incentivizing working
professionals Across the Nation to move
here and be part of our success now it
will not be easy I appreciate that we're
fighting very entrenched politically
connected bureaucracies that's the way
it always is anytime this issue comes up
and they tend to want to stifle
competition but that is not the
embodiment of who we are in the Live
Free or Die state it is not in our
spirit
I am proposing to fully remove 34
different outdated licenses from state
government eliminate 14 underutilized
regulatory boards and almost 700
unnecessary statutory provisions
[Applause]
doesn't license the contractor who
frames your house
but for some reason we licensed the guy
who's going to put a rose bush out front
think about that
not anymore
let's remember who we are let's remember
it is about individual freedom and
opportunity and opening our businesses
to everyone less red tape and more
common sense that's how we grow our
economy that is truly the New Hampshire
way
furthermore my budget creates an
independent office of regulatory review
and government efficiency to be a
watchdog to eliminate and prevent
frivolous rules and regulations as well
as to find efficiencies within state
government we're committed to breaking
down regulatory batteries we want to
lower the cost of Entry to do business
here increase free market competition
and signaling to the rest of America
that New Hampshire truly
in America for economic freedom
now in the next few months I obviously
look forward to working with all of you
very closely with members of both
parties as we deliver for the people of
our state and we can deliver to them a
fiscally responsible balanced budget
with no new taxes and no new fees we're
here to Design Systems we create
efficiencies we put people over programs
and deliver results for citizens who
sent us to Concord in the first place we
cannot let this budget be hijacked by
politics and we cannot let this budget
serve as a vehicle for partisan
maneuvering it must be about the
individual our employees our children
and our taxpayers Washington is broken
we see it every night on the news they
can manage they can barely manage to
keep the government running but that is
not how we do it in New Hampshire we are
the standard that they're constantly
trying to figure out how do we do it how
do you guys get it done are citizens
demand that level of excellence and
accountability and that transparency the
fact that we all go back to our
communities and answer questions they
have all our cell numbers it seems like
every one has mine I'm sure they all
have yours as well but that sense of
connectedness transparency and
accessibility is truly what keeps us
apart from the rest of the nation
and that type of accountability is what
we're going to deliver with this budget
good luck it's not going to be easy it's
going to be a lot of hard work we're all
in it together but I have full faith and
confidence as a team
424 plus five plus one
couple Commissioners and judges thrown
in there but really as a team we're
going to get this thing done thank you
guys very much God bless you all and God
bless this incredible state
[Applause]
representative Osborne Senator Carson
move that the joint convention arise
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it the
joint convention is adjourned
also the house will come to water
the house the house will now attend to
the continuation of the record of the
calendar beginning with house bill 260.
from the committee on Transportation
majority of the committee on
transportation to which one house will
be in order
to which was referred House Bill 260 FN
enact prohibiting the operation of Motor
Vehicles by drivers with animals on
their lapsed have been considered the
same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is in expedient
to legislate Senator John Sellers for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with a majority recommend
Report with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative Drew
Fox for the minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative bordes
speak against committee report
thank you Mr Speaker
I Rise to speak against the committee
recommendation of itl on House Bill 260.
up louder sorry is that better
okay
um number one the police are in support
of this bill
um this is a common sense bill that not
only protects human safety it protects
animal safety as well
um there are distracted driving laws but
they're based on the discretion of the
officer
this bill simply States you cannot have
an animal on the person so I can't drive
around with my dog on my lap
um there's been many examples where
people drive with dogs on their laps and
they're too busy pedophile next thing
you know they're in a motor vehicle
accident the air bear goes off and
unfortunately the dog passes away
um a 10-pound dog
would be succumbed to 300 pounds of
pressure from a deflated airbag
which would instantaneously kill the dog
other states do have similar laws but
they have so many restrictions on it so
they require require a restraint on your
dog so they would have to be buckled in
or some sort of collar attached to their
seat belt
um some also require the animal to be in
a crate while they are transported this
bill does none of that this bill simply
States your dog or your cat or your bird
cannot sit on your lap while you are
driving a motor vehicle it's as simple
as that it's for the safety of the
animal it's for the safety of
pedestrians it's the safety of the
driver
um a lot of people a lot of
misconceptions of this bill saying that
a animal would not be allowed in the
vehicle with the dog that is false
information nowhere in this bill does it
State you cannot travel with your animal
the animal just cannot be on your lap
simple as that is for the safety of
everyone including your beloved backpack
I can't tell you how many times I drive
around and I see people driving with
their dog on their lap and it's head
hanging out the driver's side window
it's just not safe also with the window
open that much and a smaller dog that
can fit on your lap you have the
potential of the dog jumping out the
window as well which
probably isn't wise
we have received multiple emails
recently in regards to this bill of
people that were previously against it
that are now for the bill after reading
it and understanding the purpose of the
bill
this bill again does not restrict
driving anywhere with your pet
so I don't want anybody to assume that
um overall I think this is a great bill
it focuses on the safety of the owner
and the animal and I highly recommend
everybody votes against the itl motion
thank you
yeah
Jay I recognize representative sellers
thank you Mr Speaker
fellows Representatives thank you for
taking the time to listen in my
report here as far as I want to EA on
itl
all right this this is just a very short
bill it's a one-off bill and it's going
to be put another burden on the police
officer to be looking over everybody's
shoulder to see if someone has a pet in
their lap or looking out the window or
something like that
but at this point here even though this
bill has Merit and its heartfelt
testimony was given New Hampshire should
not be creating another one-off bill
during our committee no statistical data
was given to back up the testimony
um in passing this bill would also
allow for a traffic stop or a citizen
even though they are not driving in an
unsafe manner
for example
you know he could actually look at this
and say
we have a
a pet and a lap bill
but then we're going to have well I
passed a pacifier to my baby how about
if I'm drinking a beverage in the car I
eat a sandwich in the car I'm using
vehicle controls we're going to have
Bill after Bill after Bill and that's
why I'm saying this bill should actually
be itl and actually I'm going to ask you
to trust the citizens of New Hampshire
and let them know and let government
stay out of intruding and infringing on
their lives and say yay and I TL this
bill
the question before us is the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislator in house bill 260.
are you ready for the question
representative Senator natasto has asked
for a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded
a division has been called
members will take their seats
this will be a division vote
it wasn't before us is the majority
committee report of inexpediate the
legislative on House Bill
260.
this will be a division vote
chair recognizes representative Eaton
for parliamentary inquiry
Mr Speaker if I know the only one who
should be in a driver's seat at any time
a vehicle is going down the road is a
driver
and Mr Speaker if I know that an animal
in a passenger seat can have a
catastrophic effect on the airbag on
both animal and driver and Mr Speaker if
I care about the motoring public if I
care about my family if I care about our
four-legged family
and want to protect them all and in 20
years of law enforcement know this has
become a progressively greater problem
over the years what I now vote know on
the itl Motions so another motion could
be brought forward
chair recognize representative Waltz for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill just
singles out one possible distraction of
many and after 20 years of commuting to
Boston there are a lot of things going
on out there
if I also know Mr Speaker that there's
only one state that has this type of
prohibition and that is Hawaii I didn't
know we ever tried to emulate them and
finally Mr Speaker
if it's determined currently under law
if a pet on your lab causes an accident
you can be charged with negligence so
it's not like the law is silent would
not wait would now would I now press the
green button
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of inexpension
legislative and house bill 260. this is
a division vote
if you're in favor you will press the
green button if you opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
thank you
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will tend to stay to the
vote
194 148 172 voting a committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on
transportation to which it was referred
House Bill 374 FN act relative to the
application process for driver's
licenses the privacy of Motor Vehicle
records considered the same report the
same with the falling resolution resolve
that is inexpedient to legislate Senator
Ted Gorski from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unwell agree
with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass Senator George Sykes from the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes
representative sites
thank you Mr speaker
members of the House colleagues
I'm going to go a little bit out of
pattern today as I talk about this bill
the first thing I want to talk about is
in the late 1880s
a person left his country
where there was violence
and
economic hard times
he was an adopted child so he didn't
quite fit in
and he made his way to this country
he was 15 years old he did it by himself
upon arrival
[Music]
he then got a job
shoveling coal by hand
for the electric plant newly designed by
Thomas Alva Edison in Providence Rhode
Island
from there
he went and raised enough money for
himself to purchase a farm in 1900.
that's the farm that he
worked and stayed in until he died his
son my grandfather
was born in that building and I lived in
that building and at that farm
up until my teens
I brought this little bit of History to
you because
I want you to think about this fact
this bill that I've introduced before
has an arc of history and the Arc of
history is that as time has come along
more and more people have seen its
wisdom so now I would call to your
attention some of the following points
that I would like to make about why this
bill is a public safety issue and has
wisdom
there are probably probably fourteen
thousand undocumented folks here in this
state
when you arrive without documentation it
isn't always because you wanted to it
could be that your parents brought you
here
undocumented them undocumented you
but the ability to drive and the ability
to prove that you know how to drive and
that you are a good driver is an
important state prerequisite and it's
important for Public Safety to
have people take that driver's test
and get their driver's license
this bill does not Grant any privileges
Beyond just that driving privileges
there were there have been
20 States and two other political
entities here in the United States that
have already passed this bill when I
first introduced this bill it was fewer
than 10. that's where I get that the Arc
of History comes along
they are currently in this state 29 000
people who are immigrants who drive
legally
we're just trying to make it possible
for people whose
the majority of whom came here like my
great-grandfather in an effort to
improve his life and in an effort to
improve their families lives this is the
right thing to do and I would urge you
to overturn the itl motion so that
another motion can be introduced and I
would request a division vote Mr Speaker
Geo recognized represent of Gorski
thank you Mr Speaker
I stand in opposition to HB 374.
if passed this bill will allow
undocumented illegal individuals to
acquire a New Hampshire driver's license
so Mr Speaker in the spirit of Saint
Valentine's Day
although there's 50 Ways to Leave a
lover according to Paul Simon
I'm going to provide you four reasons
why this bill should be it held
first this bill prohibits motor vehicle
information from being shared
with Federal immigration enforcement
agencies
so however if someone does disclose this
information to federal agencies this
person would be subject
to punishment
class of being misdemeanor which is
roughly of twelve hundred dollar fine
the person also would be civilly liable
for actual damages of of five thousand
dollars or more whatever is greater
so does it make sense to you that a
person who reports someone who may be
here illegally in our country
be punished
second election integrity
in testimonial was brought up that this
was strictly for driving
but there's nothing in the bill
that stops an undocumented person to use
it to vote
this bill cannot provide a hundred
percent guarantee that it will not be
used for voting purposes
third proponents for this bill say that
it makes things safer
that if they in fact
will get a license that they'll get in
get insurance
well this is an interesting argument
because car insurance is not required
here in New Hampshire
so then there's no tangible evidence to
support this claim in testimony
and lastly and probably the biggest
reason
this bill will make New Hampshire a
sanctuary state
so in closing I say this
driving is a privilege granted to U.S
citizens living in New Hampshire
it is not a right
with that I ask you to support the
motion of itl by pressing the green
button thank you Mr Speaker
also be in order
a division has been called this will be
a division vote members take your seats
foreign
experiential legislator and house bill
374. this will be a division vote the
chair recognizes representative value
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that HP 374 would
allow
individuals with certain religious
objections to get a license and would
also improve Road Safety by requiring
undocumented immigrants an estimated 15
000 of whom already live work and drive
in New Hampshire and otherwise meet all
the requirements for New Hampshire
residency to take the written licensing
exam and practical road test to prove
they are safe to be on our roadways and
if I know the person's having a driver's
license would help law enforcement but
providing positive identification of
individuals as well as their local
addresses and if I know that laws just
like this are already successfully on
the books and working in at least 18
states would I now press the red button
to defeat the itl so that another motion
may be made
do you recognize the representative
walled for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr speaker thank you Mr
Speaker
if I know that this bill would grant
driving privileges a privilege to drive
to people that are in our state openly
illegally
if I also know Mr Speaker that many of
these people have testified in
transportation in the past that they're
also driving illegally
we need to pass the laws so that they
can get to their jobs but however
without a social security number they're
probably working illegally
finally Mr Speaker if I also know that
this bill prohibits law enforcement from
sharing any info with Federal
immigration agencies would I now press
the green button thank you
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of any experience to
legislator and house bill 374. this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
an opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
191 voting yay 179 voting a committee
report is adopted
security
majority of the committee on
transportation to which those referred
House Bill 388 FN next relative to a
number of plates for Motor Vehicles
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is in expedient to
legislate Senator Daniel for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass Senator Charlie Sinclair for the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative of all
thank you Mr Speaker
there was two bills very similar in
nature that were filed this year
relative to use of rear license plates
only
the first bill I believe was either
retained by the committee
or voted itl in favor of this one
because it went further
that bill would have Exempted all
vehicles other than government vehicles
from requiring both a front and rear
license plate
during committee we heard from the
Department that the system won't work
with just rear license plates they need
the front license plates we were told
however there are 20 States
including Vermont
where rear license plates are the
standard
almost 30 years ago when I moved here I
was told you're moving to New Hampshire
New Hampshire has 10 months of winter
and two months of rough sledding
I I say that because all the plow trucks
driving between October and April or
March are driving around with their
front license plate blocked
all the cars
that get vanity plates are handed a
handwritten
paper plate that sits on the back of
their car for weeks on end
sometimes it's a month I was actually
told my Mac town clerk I should put it
in a plastic bag to make sure it doesn't
disintegrate before I got the real
license plate
so yet another example of a vehicle that
doesn't have a front license plate that
the system has to deal with
some said it was about the money not
allowed to use props but someone said it
was about the money but there are only
five tolls
told booths those that are manned that
don't have rear-facing cameras already
in existence
this is an important Liberty aspect and
I would ask that you would support
um
the motion to overturn the itl so that
we can bring up an auto pass motion
um we have a system that has to work
with single rear license plates anyway
why do we insist that we continue to
have front license plates on our cars
when numerous new cars don't even have
brackets to put them on thank you just
remember yield the questions
sure
remember yield you may inquire
thank you Mr Speaker would you believe
that this bill has the potential to
actually raise revenue for this date by
allowing people who only have one plate
the same pay the same cost for two if a
certain Amendment were adopted
yes I believe that it is possible with
the current structure for the the fiscal
note to raise revenue I also believe
that if we focused on trying to track
only the rear license plates we would
pick up additional revenue from the
other states that only have rear license
plates thank you
do you recognize your representative
Sykes
Mr Speaker colleagues
I I only have about two things to say
about this bill the first is that there
was
strong support on the part of the public
safety agencies to require the second
plate because a lot of crime happens
with Motor Vehicles being used in this
state and it helps identify the vehicle
and the perhaps identify the perpetrator
so that's part one part two
in an unusual thing for me
this was a true bipartisan vote on the
part of the committee
a few Democrats didn't vote with the
committee
and a few Republicans didn't vote with
the committee but the switch led to the
result that you see which was eleven
nine so that is this I want you to
remember that wasn't it nice for once
where Democrats and Republicans sitting
in Committee hearing all of the
testimony not just parts of it
agreed that this was the proper thing to
do would be to itl this bill and I would
urge you to vote so
again I would ask for a division vote
we're under the senator was asked for a
roll call vote is that sufficiently
second
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
positions
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of any expedient to
legislate on House Bill 388 this will be
a roll call vote chair recognizes
representative Sinclair for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
if I know that the Department of Motor
Vehicles only has five
toll Lanes
which have attendance attendance
from 6 a.m to 10 P.M
without a rear camera
and if I also know that the Department
of Motor Vehicles issues only one paper
plate for vanity plates which are good
for up to a year and in some cases 16
months one plate
and if I know that the Department of
Motor Vehicles only issue allows dealer
plates to be used only on the back of a
vehicle by by while being driven around
state roads
in the Department of Motor Vehicles
allows commemorative plates to cover the
front of a license of the vehicle up to
a year for anniversaries and
special occasions for towns and cities
and as if I also know that
the Department of Motor Vehicles allows
trucks and sometimes Vans to go around
with plows covering the front of their
license plate for several months of the
year if I also know that 21 states 21
States now allow for only the rear plate
to be used
and that
I also know that motor vehicles new ones
coming out now quite often do not have a
front bracket for a license plate which
causes an added representative this is
that's an entry inquiry all right sorry
I knew I was going to get caught on that
would I now ask you to encourage you to
press the red button so a better bill
can be introduced thank you
chair recognize the representative Sykes
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr
speaker if I know that according to
testimony from the New Hampshire
Department of Transportation
specifically the Bureau of turnpikes
that 53 percent of their toll revenues
that information is captured by the
front license plate
if I also know that
of this more than half of the states
that have single plate requirements are
actually in
a Southern Climate where the weather is
not such a big factor
and if I finally know
that
one of the states that was single plate
in the past Pennsylvania is currently
engaged in a process to overturn that
law and put back the second plate
because of the problems that they have
encountered
with that I would urge the
what I now urge the body to follow the
strong bipartisan vote and vote green on
the itl
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpodential
legislature on House Bill 388 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
to press a red button voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
thank you
foreign
members president an opportunity to vote
also tend to say to the vote
191 voting yay 181 voting a committee
report is adopted
the chair recognizes a clerk for a
senate message Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs that the house and its Amendment
to the following title bills is sent up
from the house to the senate senate Bill
won relative to the closing the city
Youth Services Center making
Appropriations therefore and
establishing a commission to study
Community impacts of the security Youth
Development Center
committee on transportation to which was
referred also be in order
to which was referred House Bill 597 FN
relative to race ethnicity data on
driver's licenses and race and
authenticity data collection this comes
without recommendation chair recognizes
representative Stephen Smith
the motion is ought to pass
thank you Mr Speaker
so the bill authorizes people to
voluntarily put race and ethnicity on
their licenses and requires law
enforcement to collect that information
then it does a few other things they may
or may not make that information public
and beyond that it doesn't really say
what they're going to do with it so
I get the idea of collecting data but
this isn't data it's numbers and here's
why
when you have a giant pool of potential
inputs to a data set you can have some
errors some anomalies and they're
statistically insignificant and that's
fine
we don't have a lot of people in New
Hampshire and the percentage of people
in New Hampshire that are non-caucasian
ethnicities is really small so any
anomaly in those numbers will be
statistically significant lead to
incorrect conclusions so here's an
example
let's say for the sake of argument that
people who are going to check Asian or
whatever they get on there are 50
percent less likely to self-report than
African Americans
what are the numbers that you're going
to get
what are they going to prove
the unchecked boxes well are we going to
assume that they're Caucasian when
they're actually not and then what if
there were say a thousand of each in a
given municipality and with the
underreporting of one it'll look like
the numbers from the other people have
in contact with law enforcement are much
higher but it might not be the case so
what have you proven nothing it's junk
what will we do with the numbers
presumably there's a reason to have
these numbers the bill is silent
on what we're going to do with it there
are no guard rails there are no
prohibitions you could use them for
anything
so what if in the example that I cited
the police that are collecting and
required to keep this information just
look at totals not percentages because
they can't get them and go wow when we
have interaction with I don't know
indigenous people
there are 30 percent more likely to be
armed than if we are pulling over
African-American people
might they adjust how they interact then
and that would be a tragedy because you
have no idea if those numbers are
accurate so even if you like the idea of
collecting this information and doing
some greater good with it you still
can't vote for the bill because it's a
half a plan it doesn't say what you're
going to do with the data it doesn't
validate the data and it doesn't protect
the people you're collecting the data
from
if you wanted to do this you would have
to put guidelines in place or an
oversight committee to determine what
law enforcement can do with these when
they collect them you don't know
and I'll just leave you with when you
don't know
then you can't support the bill please
votes overturn the OTP
chair recognize your representative
Sykes
thank you Mr Speaker
so House Bill 597 this is a bill which
will allow people to opt in to providing
ethnicity and race information on their
driver's licenses and the DMV testified
that their plan would be to
put a box on the driver's license with a
letter or number code that would
indicate certain things but it would not
necess it would not clearly say this
person has of this ethnicity or this
person is of that ethnicity
the issue is
there is no Statewide data now
one of the things that I learned in
looking into this bill because my first
reaction when I saw this bill my first
reaction was oh my gosh we don't want to
do that
it sounded like such a terrible idea but
as it became evident of what the goals
are of the pill it became equally
important and it became equally evident
to me that this was an important thing
to do
the data would be collected for the
first time on a Statewide basis now we
do have some police departments who are
Kalia certified
there's not a bunch of them that's a
national certification program for
police departments and it so happens
that my community of Lebanon is one of
those departments
and I've learned that
although they collect some of this data
now it is insufficient for the purposes
for which they would like it to be
applied which is to learn
whether
there's a problem or there is not a
problem in terms of stopping folks
so
here's another interesting point you
won't hear this from us often either
this bill was supported by a wide range
of organizations
and it tells you something about how
important they think it is it was
supported by the New Hampshire State
Police
it was supported by the ACLU you don't
usually hear those two names together
often
it was supported by the New Hampshire
Chiefs of Police Association
it was supported by the NAACP
and the New Hampshire Department of
Justice also came in and testified in
support of this bill these organizations
say this is important work that needs to
be done
in respect to the question about data
being good bad or indifferent data is
just data it's what you do with it that
matters I agree with my colleague from
Charlestown
the intent for this is to look for
Trends are there Trends in different
communities that help
police departments and the state police
further Define the work that they're
doing to be
effective and important
accordingly I would urge you to overturn
the
I'm sorry this is a without
recommendation I would urge you to vote
for the OTP motion
got that almost wrong
too many okay anyways that's it please
vote
OTP
[Music]
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 597. is enough Senator was
asked for a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded
this will be it and I hear division
division I heard division this will be a
division vote members take your seats
thank you
hmm
the Motions before us is ought to pass
on House Bill 597 this will be a
division vote chair recognized to
representative Walsh for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
I'm going to try to make this very quick
if I know that incomplete data is bad
data and I also know if you use bad data
you make bad decisions but I now then
press the red button thank you
house will be in order
chair recognized representative Rambo
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that HB 597fn would permit but not
require New Hampshire drivers to
self-identify their race and ethnicity
information on their licenses and if I
know that such self-identified
information has long been an important
and useful analytical tool including in
the U.S census and if I know that a wide
range of public safety law enforcement
and Community groups support this bill
including the New Hampshire State Police
the ACLU the New Hampshire police Chiefs
the Police Association the NAACP and the
New Hampshire Department of Justice
would I now vote Yes push the green
button for ought to pass thank you
motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 597 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations will be
open for 30 seconds
amazing
[Music]
representative
wall members president had an
opportunity to vote I also attend the
state of the vote
172 voting yay 200 voting nay the motion
fails
representative sellers moves in
expedient to legislate
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
as opposed nay
the eyes have it
in the committee report of inexpeding to
legislate
majority of the committee on children
and family law to which was referred
House Bill 34 FN act relative to raising
the age of marriage to 18 having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate Senator Jody
Nelson for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation to Bill ought to pass
Senator Cassandra Levesque for the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative Levesque
the marriage age in New Hampshire is 18.
but the law includes a dangerous
loophole children as defined by RSI 21b
Section 1 and RSA 1690 section 2 age 16
and 17 May marry with parental consent
and judicial approval the loophole
became law in 2018 as a step in the
right direction to end child marriage in
New Hampshire
however the loophole is still seriously
endangering 16 and 17 year old children
marriage is a serious long-term contract
to enter into any contract you have to
have the legal capacity to give consent
to legally give Valic consent a person
must possess the cognitive abilities to
understand the basic nature of marital
obligation into voluntary agree to marry
when a child is forced to marry the
perpetrators are typically the parents
parental consent is often parental
conversion
before approving a Minor's marriage a
judge must conclude that the marriage is
in the Minor's best interest however the
U.S state department has called marriage
before the for the age of 18 a human's
rights abuse
child marriages violates many human
rights including the right to education
freedom from violence access to
reproductive and Sexual Health Care
employment freedom of movement and the
right to consensual marriage and a human
rights abuse is never in the best
interest of a child
the digital review process puts a child
being forced to marry in a terrifying
position of choosing between being
honest with the court and facing
repercussions at home
testimony provided to the child and
family law committee by Unchained at
last a survivor-led non-profit working
to end force and child marriage in the
U.S through Direct Services and advocacy
stated that not one Survivor with whom
they have worked with chose to be honest
with the courts
one of the children married in New
Hampshire between 2000 and 2021 90 96
percent of children were 16 and 17 year
olds
according to data provided by child find
us in the Tahari Justice Center up to 80
percent of child marriages
up to 80 of child marriages will end in
divorce children who marry cannot get a
divorce or even enter a domestic
violence shelter in New Hampshire these
children need more not less protection
I have been approached by people who
asked but what about if a girl is
pregnant
in response we have to keep in mind that
New Hampshire according to the center of
Disease Control has the second lowest
teen pregnancy rates in the country
contrary to what U.S policy makers used
to believe pregnant teenage girls who
stay single actually have longer have
better long-term outcomes than those who
marry
teenage mothers in the U.S who married
and then divorce are more likely to
suffer economic deprivation and
instability that the teenage brothers
who stay single
we as lawmakers have an obligation to
our citizens to lead them on the path of
success
New Hampshire has made sure that the
tools to empower these girls are
available to them
they can access insurance through New
Hampshire Medicaid services are
available through New Hampshire Healthy
Families programs and start smart
programs Community Action Partnerships
can help with child care home visits and
Supportive Services
girls can get their prenatal care they
need through a variety of sources
located throughout the state
they can also get rides to their care
providers
in 2023 to think that a pregnant teen is
on their own is a ridiculously outdated
notion marriage should not be encouraged
just because it is viewed as a solution
to the problem
some will point out that teens should
not be allowed to marry their partner
should be allowed to marry their partner
who is entering the military
we need to remember that although a 17
year old can enter the military with
their parents permission however they
can also they also have to have a high
school diploma or have their GED
and in New Hampshire you have to be 18
to get your GED
if a child wants to earn their GED
earlier the child must have their
parents permission the superintendent of
their school district's permission and
pass the practice
high five subject High test before even
being eligible to take the high test
so a 17 year old cannot just enlist and
be on their way to basic Duty
what they are doing is entering the
Delayed Enlistment program which allows
them to delay
enlistment for up to 365 days and even
then they can choose to withdraw from
the program if they change their mind or
if they are not ready or if they want to
go to college instead
child marriage has no redeeming
qualities period
it offers no benefits to children that
cannot and should not be found elsewhere
and it brings countless serious harms
and risk we do not allow exceptions to
drinking smoking or driving ages we set
those ages based on when people can
safely engage in those activities we
should not do the same with marriage
which the question we should be asking
is not why we want to end child marriage
but instead why are those why are there
others advocating to allow adults to
marry children
how much longer will we wait before it
is time to stop this practice how many
more victims will there be how many more
lives will be destroyed the time to end
child marriage is not in the future the
time is now thank you
also be in order
there's a member yield to questions
there's a member yield the questions
member does not yield
chair recognizes Senator Nelson
thank you Mr Speaker and good afternoon
to my friends here in the house
I Rise to speak in favor of the
committee recommendation of an
inexpedient to legislate regarding house
bill 34. to make absolutely sure I was
providing credible information to you
today yesterday I directly contacted the
New Hampshire Vital Records Office and
asked them to provide me with a number
of marriages recorded in New Hampshire
where at least one party of the marriage
was under 18 years of age from the years
2019 to 2022
there were five in 2019 zero in 2020
one in 2021 and 0 in 2022.
the reason it's important that I queried
that data set is that in 2018 some
important pieces of legislation were
passed in this house was strong
bipartisan support and signed into law
specifically relating to minors Desiring
to marry these laws do not make it easy
to obtain a marriage license if one or
both individuals is 16 or 17 years of
age additionally if in the rare occasion
that permission to marry is granted
legislation has been put into place to
make sure that these individuals have
protections under the law
presently some of what is required by
law in order for underage marriage to
occur in New Hampshire includes
the parents or Guardians applying and
writing to the judicial branch Family
Division for permission to contract such
marriage as part of the decision-making
process the court May conduct an
in-camera interview of each person under
the age of consent without that person's
parent or guardian or the other party to
the proposed marriage present
no permission shall be granted to
persons below the age of consent if both
parties are non-residents
in no circumstance shall a Justice or
judge Grant permission to marry if
sexual contact or sexual sexual
penetration between the parties would
but for the solemnization of the
proposed marriage constitutes sexual
assault felonious sexual assault or
aggravated felonious sexual assault
permission to contract such marriage
shall be granted only upon clear and
convincing evidence that the marriage is
in the best interest of the person or
persons below the age of consent
and they're very rare instance that an
underage marriage should occur statute
protects the minor in such that the
certificate of marriage shall provide
evidence of a Minor's emancipation
by the act of emancipation the minor can
file court cases enter contracts and
make financial and medical decisions for
themselves
a concern that was heard in testimony in
our committee was that as a minor the
husband or wife wouldn't have access to
domestic violence advocacy should they
become a victim of abuse that's just not
the case in fact stakeholders have
Outreach programs to get help for teens
who are victims of partner abuse
this brings me to share some concerning
data a study conducted by UNH revealed
that one in 10 teenagers in a
heterosexual relationship reported being
a victim of teen physical and or sexual
Dating Violence in the prior year with
sexual minority teens reporting rates
more than twice that of teens and
heterosexual relationships
HB 34 would do nothing to help these
unmarried teens who are experiencing
abuse from a partner as legislators and
Community leaders we need to put our
efforts into helping this population of
teens where the real problem is not
support legislation to fix a problem
that isn't and for these reasons I ask
you to press the green button to itl
hb34 thank you
the motion before us is the
I'm sorry just remember yielded
questions member does not yield
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of in expedient to
legislator and house bill 34.
are you ready for the question
the vision has been requested members
take your seats
[Music]
foreign
Expedia to legislate on houseboat 34.
this will be a division vote chair
recognizes representative long for a
parliamentary inquiry
Mr Speaker if I know that ending a child
marriage allows girls and boys to
continue as children
and if I further know that Society has
developed from the 60s and 70s whereas
marrying at an older age couples mayor
are marrying at an older age then when I
press the red button thank you Mr
Speaker
Joe recognizes representative Mark
Pearson for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Mr
Mr Steen just a few years ago
and since 2020 we have had one
one marriage where at least one party in
the marriage was under 18 according to
the state division of Vital Records
and if I know that for a marriage of a
16 or 17 year old to take place such
marriage must
be approved by the parents involved and
also by a judge and for good cause
and if I know that if the marriage
doesn't work out there are legal
remedies on the books for dissolution of
that marriage
what I now honor the freedom of those
very very few young people to marry at
such an age by pressing the green button
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of inexpediate the
legislative in house bill 34. this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if your opposer
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
represent Gould
members president had an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
188 quote a day 184 voting a committee
report is adopted
the committee on criminal justice and
Public Safety to which was referred
House Bill 560 F A an act establishing a
contact person notification program to
assist law enforcement Personnel who
have contact with a person with mental
or physical disabilities and making an
appropriation therefore having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation at the bill atsu pass
representative Karen Reed for the
committee the question is on the
majority committee report about to pass
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
as have it
[Music]
House Bill 560 FNA is referred to the
committee on finance
the majority of the committee on
education which is referred House Bill
309 FN and act relative to civil rights
education in public elementary and
secondary schools have been considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that it is
in expedient to legislative
representative Olive for Ford for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill Ocho pass
representative Mike Belcher for the
minority of the committee
what reason does remember rise
move to table 309
representative Ladd moves to table House
Bill 309 are you ready for the question
representative luno requests a division
vote this will be a division vote
members take receipts
thank you
foreign
the
motion to lay House Bill 309 on the
table representative Ladd is recognized
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know this bill proposes that within
the national and State history and
government classes that instruction
include Armenian Genocide the Holocaust
Chinese Coulee labor in Cuba the uyghurs
of China and rohinga a Perma of Burma
while the bill makes no mention of
injustices that have occurred in our own
country
if I know that student knowledge of
genocide end of the Holocaust are
required as part of an adequate
education pursuant to RSA 193e thus
making this bill duplicative
if I further know the council general of
the Turkish Consulate in Boston
communicated educating young minds with
such a curriculum
would also potentially risk the exposure
of young children of the law abiding
Turkish Armenian community in New
Hampshire to discrimination and
disenfranchence franchisement in schools
and elsewhere and lastly if I also know
this bill would result in Department
having to purchase additional
instructional materials for a
distribution to Public Schools as well
as hiring an additional part-time
employee to oversee this requirement
would I then press the green button to
table hb309
representative Miler is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that HB 309 is not necessary
because the content of this bill is
already part of the state curriculum
dictated by the academic standards of
the Department of Education
and if I know that the current statutes
authorize local control by school boards
to determine the manner in which
curriculum will be delivered
if I know that this very bill was
considered in 2022 house session and was
not deemed ready for consideration by
this body
if I know these facts Mr Speaker would I
now press the red button so that an
alternative motion can be placed before
this body thank you Mr Speaker
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 309 on the table this is a division
vote if you're in favor of tabling
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
thank you
[Music]
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
183 having voted in the affirmative 184
and the negative the motion fails
the question is back to the majority
committee report of an expediential
legislate
for what reason does a member rise
representative Leon has recognized to
speak against the committee report
thank you Mr Speaker
as the great granddaughter of an
Armenian architect
I know that the wounds of things like
this Run Deep
I know that it's not just me that has
this history
but I know that there are so many
misunderstandings about what has
happened
about whether people who are still who
are not alive who are descendants of
those on either side should be held
accountable and they shouldn't
there is no Turk alive today who
participated in the Armenian Genocide
just as other tragedies throughout
history were not part of it we still
have great understandings under
misunderstandings about how this can
happen how people that were once friends
could end up slaughtering each other and
it requires a curriculum that can help
us get into these deep issues and look
at them and try and understand how we
can prevent ourselves and how we can
prevent others from falling from
disagreement to Great tragedy
while this bill is not perfect the
amendment does make it better by
recognizing other tragedies the Holloman
door
the Trail of Tears and others and it's
not exclusionary the point is to make
people realize the tragedy happens the
unspeaking Unspeakable happens between
groups and we need to understand that
and recognize that the member will
suspend for a moment
it's like to remind you there is no
Amendment before us right now I
apologize
I apologize Mr speaker so if there was a
emotion but this bill should be able to
continue on so that another motion can
be made because we need to look at how
individuals can end up
being parts of packs of rabid animals
trying to kill each other
that is a very and I'm not speaking to
any particular group we all know that
Warren groups have done this from time
immemorial this is a flaw of The Human
Condition
that we must address so I ask you to
overturn the itl by pushing the red
button
the member from Hopkinson representative
luno is recognized to speak for the
committee for the committee report yep
thank you very much Mr Speaker House
Bill 309 was recommended in expedient to
legislate with a strong bipartisan vote
of 12 to 8. the committee rejected the
bill for many reasons but in the
nutshell
current law already establishes the
content of inadequate education and
grants authority to school districts to
develop curriculum
for those content areas
this bill is unnecessary and constitutes
an overreach of state government to
impose strict curriculum requirements on
every school in every city and town
across the state
many residents also found the bill to be
offensive and risks exposing children to
discrimination in schools and in their
communities
its heavy-handed big government and most
definitely not the New Hampshire way
please support the strong bipartisan
committee report of Ito thank you Mr
Speaker and I do request a division vote
the questions on the majority committee
report of inexpediant to legislate
representative Luna requests a division
vote this will be a division vote
members taker seats
thank you
the questions on the committee majority
committee report of an expedience
legislate
representative Miler is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that HB 309 is not necessary
because the content of this bill is
already part of the curriculum dictated
by the academic standards of the
Department of Education
and if I know that the current statutes
authorize local control by school boards
to determine the manner in which
curriculum will be delivered and if I
know that this very bill was considered
in 2022 in this session it was not
deemed ready for consideration by this
body if I know these facts Mr Speaker
would I now press the green button and
send support for the itl motion thank
you
the questions on the majority committee
report of inexpedency legislate this is
a division vote if you're in favor of an
expedient to legislate you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
253 having voted in the affirmative 118
and the negative the majority committee
reports adopted
[Music]
the committee on education which was
referred House Bill 419 FNA an act
relative to the math learning
communities program of the community
college system and making an
appropriation therefore having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation at the bill Ocho pass
representative Rick Ladd for the
committee the questions on the majority
committee report about to pass are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed name
Okie dokes the eyes have it and House
Bill 419 is referred to the committee on
finance
the majority of the committee on
education which was referred to House
Bill 420 FNA an act relative to the
availability and funding for the Dual
and concurrent enrollment program by the
community college system and making an
appropriation therefore having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative Rick Ladd for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same in being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Mike Belcher for the minority of the
committee
representative Santa nostazo requests of
roll calls that's sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded
the questions on the majority committee
report of
odd to pass you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those posne
the eyes have it and the committee
reports adopted
and House Bill 420 is referred to the
committee on finance
the chair recognizes the clerk to read a
report Mr Speaker the committee on
enrolled bills has examined and found
correctly enrolled the following title
bills Senate bill Senate Bill 1 relative
to the closing of the sununu Youth
Services Center making Appropriations
thereof in establishing a commission to
study Community impacts of the secured
Youth Development Center
thank you
the committee on education which was
referred House Bill 420 FN local
requiring the offering of breakfast and
lunch and all public Uncharted schools
comes to us without recommendation
representative Ellison moves Archer pass
and offers Amendment 0170h
[Music]
the question is whether to adopt the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposing a
[Music]
the motion fails
know what
Mr Speaker
thank you
all right so
hi for what reason does it memorize I
have
to stay in motion uh
okay
that's representative Ellison moves at
House Bill 429 be laid on the table
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
this will be a division vote members
take your seats
okay thank you
thank you
this is
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 429 on the table
this is a division vote representative
Ellison is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that children perform better
in school when they're not hungry and if
I know that 456 New Hampshire Public
Schools already participate in the
federal breakfast and lunch program and
if I know that this legislation will
provide healthy meals for more children
from New Hampshire's educationally
disadvantaged families and Mr Speaker if
I believe that feeding hungry children
is not just a democratic issue or a
republican issue but one on which we
should all agree that now I would say we
should table the legislation and bring
it back in a different format at a
different time
thank you Mr Speaker
the question is when to lay House Bill
429 on the table this is a division vote
if you're in favor of tabling you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
foreign
members presence had an opportunity to
vote
the house will attended the state of the
190 and the affirmative 173 and the
negative House Bill 429 is laid on the
table
thank you
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 430 FN local
relative to applications for the
education Freedom accounts program this
comes without recommendation
representative luno moves on a pass
chair recognizes representative
McDonald McDowell
thank you Mr chair I am representative
Valerie McDonald and I'm fortunate to
represent my friends and Neighbors in
Salem with respect to my colleagues I
Rise to oppose House Bill 430 attending
public school for one year does not add
transparency and does not add
accountability
instead it is detrimental to low-income
students wishing to put their families
tax dollars towards choice
every child is unique and learns
differently according to the Nea
therefore education is not meant to be
one size fits all
moreover no student should be barred
from educational Excellence based on
their parents ability to pay
the current program provides these EFA
students with options with choice and
with success not vouchers
in addition the bill in front of us
contains no exception for siblings or
students already qualified for an EFA
that would harm parents who would be
forced to drive between multiple schools
this is an unnecessary hardship on
Granite State families including those
choosing to make New Hampshire their
home too
by restricting access to those who have
attended a New Hampshire Public School
no allowance is made for out-of-state
students
as a result this would discourage
settling down here
we would lose our Workforce potential
and the opportunity to educate the Next
Generation
for these reasons when the motion of OTP
came before the education committee not
only did I vote no I yelled no way
I continue to say that in front of you
as a product to public schools and as a
recent graduate of a public school
but the model does not fit every student
EFA students Excel and exceed
expectations despite economic adversity
that is why access should not be delayed
an entire year at the child's expense
in the words of Reverend Dr King Jr or
write delayed is a right denied
finally knowing that the program was
theorized in Senate Bill 130 of 2021 to
be universally accessible today's
attempt to restrict access must be
opposed I repeat restrictions must be
opposed
so please join me in voting against
OTP to defend parents rights
school choice and most importantly kids
across our state
thank you and Mr Speaker I request a
roll call vote please
the house will be in order
chair recognized representative luno
thank you Mr Speaker when the education
Freedom account program was introduced
two years ago the commissioner of
education and others presented how the
EFA program would be an opportunity for
students who are not succeeding in their
Public Schools
and needed to make a change
to provide an alternative to their local
public school
of course we all know that's not true
other alternatives are and have been
available to all students and families
such as charter schools and attendance
at Public Schools outside of the
residence School District through the
state's relatively new manifest hardship
law that we worked on together in 2019
collaboratively with Republicans
Democrats and stakeholders
but still the commissioner of Education
made the case for efas based on helping
students who do not have the resources
to leave their public school and choose
an alternative for their education needs
and and this is a big point to so in a
way that results in substantial savings
for the local property taxpayer so they
would no longer have to pay the local
cost to educate that student
but that's not what happened
according to the Department of Education
there are currently three thousand
twenty five children enrolled in the EFA
program that is offering grants totaling
nearly 15 million dollars this school
year the cost to taxpayers would be
about 65 million dollars if those 3 000
students who are all eligible attended a
traditional public school that's a
direct quote from the Department of
Education
but also according to the department
only about 680 students actually left
their public school to join the program
vast majority of students were not
attending public school at all they were
already at private schools or home
schools but in any event they certainly
weren't costing taxpayers 65 million
dollars
in fact they were costing taxpayers
nothing
say that again
based on the Department's own numbers 80
percent of EFA students were already in
private or home schools and not costing
taxpayers a dime
a program was enacted as part of the
2022-2023 state budget to give students
attending Public Schools a choice in the
education
with an estimated cost to taxpayers in
the budget of three million dollars
but because nearly all of the students
now in the program were already
attending private or home schools the
EFA program has cost taxpayers more than
23 million dollars so far and the
commissioner of education has requested
an additional 60 million dollars for the
next two years as one of our
constituents said to me quote there's
nothing conservative about this program
so House Bill 430 clears this up saves
taxpayers millions of dollars and makes
sure the EFA program doesn't turn into a
taxpayer-funded private school tuition
bill payment
well simply requires students to be
enrolled in their public school when
they apply for an EFA exception is made
for students who are entering
kindergarten or first grade
we're committed to improving the
accountability oversight and
transparency of the EFA program would
the commissioner now asking for 60
million dollars more of taxpayer money
in the next budget it's more important
than ever that taxpayers know how their
money is being spent and the results
at the motion of OTP to prevent taxpayer
dollars from being used to pay private
school tuition bills thank you Mr
Speaker
so remember you have the questions
member does not yield
representative McDonald has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 430. this will be a roll call
vote
chair recognizes representative Cora
tiello for a parliamentary inquiry
speaker
Mr Speaker
if I know that the purpose of Education
Freedom accounts is to enable parents to
send their children to the school of
their choice
and if I believe
that it is unreasonable to require
parents to First send their children to
a school that is not of their choice in
order to qualify for an education
Freedom account
and finally
if I believe that parents unencumbered
by the state have the fundamental right
to decide how their children are
educated
to support increased Educational
Opportunity would I now vote no and push
the red button
do you recognize representative Milo for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that of the 3200 EFA taxpayer
vouchers issued only 100 of the students
switching out of the public schools
meaning that the other EFA participants
had already been in private or religious
schools
and if I believe that the current
recipients of the EFA vouchers had
already chosen private and religious
schools
if I believe that HB 430 restores the
original intent of the taxpayer vouchers
allowing public school students to
exercise their school choice option
if I believe these facts Mr Speaker
would I now press the green button and
support the ought to pass motion thank
you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 430. it's a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed to press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
[Music]
well members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
the speaker the speaker did vote to
create the tie
for what reason as a member rise like to
make a motion
who is first
Mr Speaker I move in expedient to
legislate Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker I'd like to make a motion to
table
it's a higher priority motion
so the motion before us is the table
House Bill 430. the division has been
requested
all members take their seats
who requested the road
representative Rover requests the roll
call is that sufficiently second that it
is sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote
thank you
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 430
this will be a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
awesome
wall members president an opportunity to
vote
house will attend to the state of the
186.48 183 voting a
motion to table passes
representative seaworth declared a
conflict of interest and did not
participate
[Music]
the house will be in order
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 487 FN establishing
a New Hampshire Farm to school
reimbursement program this comes without
recommendation
representative Tanner moves ought to
pass
and offers floor Amendment zero one zero
three
zero one o three h
there is no debate but there will be a
parliamentary inquiries
[Music]
okay
oh oh I was just going to explain it
chair recognizes Lieutenant Simpson
um thank you Mr Speaker I'll be very
brief I just wanted to say that the
amendment is an oversight the um of the
in drafting and that it didn't add the
state's part of the reimbursement policy
to the appropriation so the amendment
shows the um two to one ratio of federal
state federal to State money that we are
hoping
um to have to run the farm to school
reimbursement policy program thank you
and we'd like a division vote on the
amendment please
the motion before us is the amendment
0103h this is a division vote on the
amendment
members take your seats
foreign
h on House Bill 487 this is a division
vote
chair recognizes representative Ladd for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you very much Mr Speaker
if I know in order to initiate the New
Hampshire Farm to school program this
amendment appropriates the sum of 745
thousand dollars for the fiscal year
ending June 30 2024.
and if I understand that of this sum 145
000 shall be for hiring another employee
to manage the program with another fifty
thousand dollars to support
informational technology relate related
to the program
and if I also understand that such an
expense is not necessary as schools May
currently contract and work with local
farmers to develop their own Farm to
school program without needed State
support would I then press the red
button
chair recognizes representative Murray
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
amendment is not only a Sound Investment
in New Hampshire's children but also an
investment in our challenging farming
industry and our local New Hampshire
economy and if I further know that by
supporting local farming and
supplementing School meals with
nutritionally dense locally sourced
foods that geography and Regional
knowledge of where our food comes from
would become a conversation at lunch
tables across New Hampshire and if I
further know that local economies would
then be supported while feeding children
more than nutritionally dense food would
I now press the green button in support
of this win-win-win for New Hampshire
students schools economies and Farms
thank you
the motion before us is the amendment
0103h on to house bill
487. this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you opposed to press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
[Music]
one members president an opportunity to
vote
house will attend the state of the road
183 voting a 181 voting a the amendment
passes
we're on to on a pass with Amendment
chair recognizes representative
panternell
thank you Mr Speaker
I Rise before you today to ask that you
vote no on House Bill 487.
we can all agree that New Hampshire
values its extensive history of farming
the quaintness of the New England Farm
and the contribution of farms to our
vibrant local communities and
agritourism
we can also agree that good nutrition is
of the utmost important to importance to
our students ensuring healthy minds and
bodies
however this program is unnecessary in
our schools at this time
for one reason there is nothing to
prevent local school districts from
establishing such a program
the state gives districts local control
and they are welcome to reach out to
Farms across the state to determine what
local products are available for
purchase to be served in their own
schools
there are already
175 such programs established across the
state without
a state mandated program
only schools that participate in the
national school lunch program would be
eligible for Farm to school benefits
this bill would also require the
establishment of a new position in the
department of education for the sole
purpose of administering this program
there would be an initial cost to the
state of one hundred and forty five
thousand dollars just to establish this
position
fifty thousand dollars for the purpose
of the technology to write the code for
its Administration and schools will be
only eligible to receive up to twelve
hundred dollars in reimbursement I'm
pretty sure twelve hundred dollars is
what my family spends on groceries in a
month
I didn't so this
this is an additional cost of six
hundred thousand dollars for a total of
745 000 that will not lapse
finally it is questionable that there
are enough Farms willing to participate
it is questionable that enough food is
grown in New Hampshire to make this a
worthwhile Endeavor and we are unsure
how many schools would even be
interested in taking advantage of this
program
although we love our farms and we love
our children for these reasons I urge
you to vote no
do you recognize representative Murray
Happy Valentine's Day to you all as a
parent mother teacher and someone who
grows some of her own food for home use
nothing would make the community of
folks I represent happier than to see
our lunches in schools across New
Hampshire move forward reflecting more
locally sourced meals wherever possible
it is true that New Hampshire has a
small farming Community when compared to
neighboring states but it is also true
that those Farms are precious to New
Hampshire and are committed to Food
Safety and Security of our Granite
Staters our state's Farms fisheries and
producers are the lifeline to keeping
Regional food in our homes and hopefully
with this bill more of it in our school
lunches too
through this bill the voluntary program
will provide New Hampshire K-12 schools
who participate in the national school
lunch program estate reimbursement for
purchases of New Hampshire grown and
produced Foods the program's
reimbursement rate is one dollar for
every three spent with a maximum
reimbursement of twelve hundred dollars
per School
participating schools can maximize their
reimbursement benefit by spending 300
excuse me three thousand six hundred
dollars of their federal school lunch
funds on New Hampshire grown and
produced food in order to receive the
1200 reimbursement from the state as
administered by the New Hampshire's
Department of Ed
this program will annually inject 1.8
million dollars of federal and state
funds directly into New Hampshire's Farm
and Food economy it is a win-win-win if
we invest in New Hampshire's Farms
students and schools in this way
parents across New Hampshire value
locally sourced food and ensuring our
school lunches better reflect that is
important to our constituents this bill
has an opportunity through funding for
the doe to stand up a program that would
continue to further work of connecting
our students to the rich variety of
locally sourced nutrient-dense foods
from New Hampshire
that producers grow and make who knows
some students may go on to become
Farmers Fishers or maple syrup producers
as a result of seeing a myriad of Foods
New Hampshire can provide to its
communities from value-added products
like yogurts and squash to squashes and
many other types of food we grow and
Source in New Hampshire this program
matters
children should have the opportunity to
know that just off the coast comes the
cod in their fish sticks
from the Rolling Hills of Southern New
Hampshire come the beautiful fruits and
their squash may actually be grown in
cold grown in Colebrook and of course
their maple syrup for the breakfast for
lunch days may come from many regions
throughout the state
I ask you to support such a creative
solution that provides the opportunity
to invest in New Hampshire's farming
fishing and food producing communities
while supporting locally nutritious food
this bill would help us spend 10 percent
of the money we spend on local school
lunches Statewide in our state it's a
start I ask that you support the motion
of opt to pass as amended and please
press the green button in support of
economic growth farming communities and
nutrition and Mr Speaker I kindly ask
for a division vote
remember yielded questions
remember it does not yield
foreign
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded
this will be a division vote
members take your seats
[Music]
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 487. this is a
division vote
chair recognizes
Senator Vlad for a parliamentary inquiry
if I know that locally grown food has
many benefits
that some New Hampshire public schools
are taking advantage of locally grown
foods without the need for a state
program
not further understand that a number of
communities along the Connecticut River
and elsewhere along our state's borders
Define local as they do in my neck of
the woods as both sides of the river
Vermont and New Hampshire
if I also know that a year-round program
located in New Hampshire must have
sustainable source of foods for the farm
to to school program to work and in
order for this state to do so the food
source may have to be extended otherwise
the definition of local may have to be
extended beyond our borders to include
New England and possibly New York State
and Pennsylvania
if I then believe that this program is
not ready would I then press the red
button
do you recognize the represent of Tanner
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know the amendment cleared up any
issue was the designation of local farm
products it's not supplying the year the
whole meal it's snacks and foods and it
also
clears up the definition of what a local
Farm is by extending a range of miles
and if I know this bill is enabling it
legislation that allows schools to
participate in a win win win
for students local farmers in our
community
would I now vote green to support this
great bill that will bring healthy foods
to students
will connect our students to where their
food comes from in our local farms and
support local Farm families thank you
the motion before us as Auto pass is
amended on House Bill 487 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
to press the red button voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
foreign
ER
members will remain in their seat we're
still in the voting mode
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
181 voting yay 187 voting nay
the motion fails
Mr Speaker
for what reason does a member arise
Mr Speaker I'd like to make a motion to
table
it is a proper motion a motion before us
is the table house bill 487.
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested
members should be in your seat still
the motion before us is the table house
bill 487.
this will be a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
of your opposed or press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
thank you
okay
representative
there we go thank you
Wellman was president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
the vote
195 voting a 172 voting a the motion to
table passes
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 521 FNA act relative
to Department of Education payment for
placement of an episode of treatment
have been considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass Senator Glenn
cordelli for the committee
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay you always have it and
the committee report is adopted and it
is sent to finance
committing on education to which was
referred House Bill
542 FNA
enact establishing an academic research
and Improvement performance data analyst
in the Department of Education having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass Senator Rick Ladd for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
there's opposed nay the eyes have it in
the committee report is adopted and it
is the report is uh the bill is sent to
finance
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 626 FN requiring the
Department of Education to administer
the education Freedom account this comes
without recommendation representative
lunomu's Auto pass chair recognizes
representative Belgium
thank you Mr Speaker honorable members
this is a fairly simple bill in theory
but the effects of it are difficult to
overstate
so the the bill takes the education
Freedom account
and it transfers the administration of
that account from where it currently
lies in the private sector with a
non-profit company that is going to be
up for bid
to the Department of Education and the
executive branch
now
the first thing we should know is that
the Department of Education as of right
now it has no personnel and no
infrastructure to support this change we
were able to get this program up and
running in record time Nationwide
because we outsourced that to the
private sector to get that done it's
entirely possible that if we do this if
we pass this bill and give it to the
Department of Education we can
experience a lapse we could experience
difficulty in getting this funding out
there's no guarantees if we do this
here we have the cost of the program you
may hear arguments that the cost is too
high but according to our numbers we see
that the administrative costs and the
current program are running within the
mean for the public education sector and
that includes startup costs
startup costs were quite expensive now
that those costs are over we fully
expect these costs to continue coming
down over time
that would not happen necessarily if we
gave it to the Department of Education
and I will also note that when we
receive this bill in education there was
no fiscal note with it it wasn't
produced in time we have no idea what
they are suggesting this would cost if
we gave it to the Department of
Education
as I mentioned open bidding on this
program should be coming up pretty soon
the member will suspend
if you need to have a conversation take
it out into the Annie room the member
has a right to be heard
thank you Mr Speaker
you may also hear an argument that there
is too much or doubled up Administration
over this program I would note this bill
does nothing to address any concerns
about how much Administration is
occurring in the program because all it
would do it was is it would take it from
the private sector and put it in the
public sector that is not a reduction in
administration by any means
currently the program is transparent you
can access the funding information on
the internet
and that is why I am asking you to
oppose
ought to pass on this bill and Mr
Speaker I would request a roll call
Jr recognizes representative luno
thank you very much Mr Speaker House
Bill 626 would require the New Hampshire
Department of Education to administer
the education Freedom account program
that's right
hb626 would have a department that's
currently responsible for over 165
000 New Hampshire students to administer
a program that serves approximately 3
200 students
so what's the big deal
in New Hampshire the EFA program is not
actually managed by the Department of
Education as in other states with these
School voucher programs
it's managed by a private contractor
this contractor skims 10 percent of our
taxpayer dollars right off the top to
keep for themselves
and that needs to change
but wait according to a conservative
activist organization quote the EFA
program has been running efficiently end
quote so let's look into that claim
when the EFA program was created two
years ago it did not get support from
any legislative committee and was jammed
into the state budget with an estimated
cost of three million dollars
but to date the program has cost New
Hampshire taxpayers nearly 25 million
dollars and the commissioner has
requested another 60 million dollars for
this over the next two years
that doesn't sound conservative to me
neither does the nine million dollars of
that taxpayer money that the contractor
gets to keep
according to their website they have
seven employees and a current and former
legislator on their board efficient
really I bet most of our constituents
would call that something else
that same conservative activist group
also notes quote this bill would also
restrict the near the yearly test
assessments
that families may choose from and
require them to take a state
standardized test
and that's right taxpayers should know
what they're getting for their precious
tax dollars
we're committed to improving the
accountability oversight and
transparency of the EFA program would
the commissioner now asking for 60
million more dollars of taxpayer money
in the next budget it's more important
than ever that taxpayers know how their
money is being spent and the results
support the motion of ought to pass to
protect taxpayer dollars from being
wasted and I thank you Mr Speaker
there has been a requests for a roll
call vote is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
[Music]
thank you
members take your seats
motion before us
is ought to pass on House Bill 626.
this will be a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative quartetello
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
if I know that the current
administration of the education Freedom
account is efficient and effective with
90 cents of every dollar going to help
New Hampshire children
and if I know that the Department of
Education currently has neither the
staff or the infrastructure to run an
EFA program and finally if I believe
that a private non-profit organization
reapproved annually by the New Hampshire
Department of Revenue for efficient
fiscal management is best equipped to
run the education Freedom account
program
to maintain a smooth running program
would I now vote no and push the red
button
do I recognize representative Tanner for
parliamentary inquiry
is administered by a private non-bid
contractor who receives 10 percent of
taxpayer resourced funds currently at
2.3 million dollars to administer this
program
and if I know moving the administration
to the Department of Education
the EFA voucher program will be five
financially more responsible and will
provide for transparency accountability
and oversight
for the Department
would I now vote green on the ought to
pass
for fiscal and academic accountability
thank you
the motion before us is auto pass and
house bill 626. it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press a
red button the voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will tend to stay to the
vote
under an 83 voting
positive 180 in the negative the motion
passes
or what member does the reason as a
member Mr Speaker having voted on the
prevailing
the bill is referred to finance
majority of the committee on education
to which was referred house
Bill 638 FM local an act relative to
extraordinary needs grants to schools
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass Senator Rick Ladd for
the majority of the committee
chair recognizes Alicia leakis
representative Alicia leakis
thank you Mr Speaker
every year since the 70s
Ed
population in the schools has been going
down
money spent on the schools has been
going up
and
outcomes have been going either staying
steady or going down
but we keep spending sending more money
to fix it more money to fix it but we
don't know where it's going we don't
know what it's being used for
so yet again another program was started
last year
to send yet again more money to schools
that have problems okay
but we said
when you do that
we want to know we want you to have a
plan what are you going to use it for
and at the end of the time did it work
that's all we asked for what are you
going to use it for come up with a plan
how is this going to work
but now it's one year later and they're
saying oh
if it's 50 000 a small sum of money
fifty thousand you don't have to do a
report because too much money is spent
in doing the report I ask you fifty
thousand dollars and you can't write a
report
so at any rate
I would urge you to vote no on this
because let's
let's hold people accountable let's hope
that maybe the money just doesn't
I don't actually know what because we
never know what let's let's get a report
let's find out let's make people put a
plan in place before we give them more
money thank you
I recognize representative Ladd
the extraordinary needs Grant is part of
the education funding for schools
and there's a grant that we put in place
a year ago
approximately 17 million dollars for for
the year
this this uh process that we established
was to assist those schools with that
had these extraordinary needs and we
rode into it the house wrote in an
accountability plan you receive the
money you write this accountability plan
however when you distribute this money
over all the schools
some schools are receiving a thousand
dollars
two thousand dollars very little amounts
this bill was constructed and submitted
To Us by the Department of Education in
an effort to streamline this program and
allow those districts which are very
small schools like these k-3s k-4s to
allow this to be unrestricted money to
assist them as we do with all other
aspects of the education formula so I
would encourage you to support the
department of education's request and
send this bill on to the finance
committee where we will be discussing
all three of these areas be it the
relief Grant be it extraordinary grants
or be it the fiscal capacity all that as
the governor mentioned this morning
needs an overhaul so let's send this
thing on as the Department's asking to
the finance committee and resolve
this whole process thank you
the motion before us is the majority
report about a pass and House Bill 638
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it
and the committee report is adopted and
this bill will be sent to finance
committee on Election law to which was
referred House Bill 324 FNA relative to
campaign contributions and expenditures
into making appropriation therefore this
bill is
been sent to us without recommendation
Senator Muirhead moves ought to pass
chair recognizes representative Berry
Union
thank you Mr Speaker I rise today to
oppose the ox path motion on HB 324 HP
324 is a six million dollar expenditure
which it does in its attempt to get
money out of politics it takes money out
of the taxpayers wallets and then puts
more money into politics it will not
accomplish the things that it claims to
do it will end up it is colloquially
known in other states where it has been
put in as the political operative
bailout fund because what it does is it
takes your tax dollars and gives it to a
campaign that would not otherwise be
able to raise them finally this law
violates the Constitution because in the
Constitution you have this thing called
right to freedom of Association so when
the government takes your money and then
gives it to a candidate that you don't
support that violates your freedom of
Association and your freedom of speech
we do need to work on our campaign
Finance laws we just passed
comprehensive campaign Finance reform
but this is a six million dollar
taxpayer-funded boondoggle and I asked
the body to reject it
chair recognizes recognizes
representative Muirhead
thank you Mr Speaker
before any candidate faces voters
the candidates especially for Statewide
offices have to succeed in a different
primary they have to succeed in the
donor primary they have to appeal to
out-of-state donor Elites if they're
going to run a viable campaign
they appeal to people who don't
understand New Hampshire don't live in
New Hampshire and are committed to New
Hampshire
I was just talking to a campaign
strategist about
candidates who might run in the next
gubernatorial cycle and the strategist
told me that candidates have to pass the
Rolodex test
which in which they uh they are grilled
about how many big donors they know and
how much money they can raise out of
state
this bill seeks to disempower the
out-of-state Elite donor class and
re-empower New Hampshire voters
and it does it in a very simple way it
gives every voter for 25 certificates
that they can give to any candidate for
executive counselor governor of their
choice
it turns voters into donors
and gives candidates with real support
in the population a chance to run a
viable campaign
my friend and colleague from the great
city of Manchester just said that a bill
such as this would Empower candidates
who are weak but that's not true because
in order to qualify for donor for for
voter dollars candidates have to collect
large numbers of very small donations
for an executive counselor would have to
collect 500 donations of at least five
dollars to qualify you can't do that
unless people in your District know you
people in your District appreciate you
people in your District want you to run
gubernator trail candidates that have to
collect 2500 five dollar donations that
shows real local support
my friend and colleague suggest that a
bill like this might be unconstitutional
but in fact plants like this have been
tested and work we have public financing
of campaigns in Maine we have public
financing campaigns in Washington they
haven't been declared unconstitutional
we have a presidential campaign election
fund that you might notice when you're
filling out your 1040 over the next
month or two if there's a check box you
can give three dollars to the fund these
are not considered to be
unconstitutional and this one won't be
either
foreign
this idea was formed in a bipartisan
study committee
and it was introduced in an earlier
version a couple sessions ago this
particular bill has been refined and
revised in light of criticisms and
suggestions that have come from members
of both parties including former chairs
of the election law committee
this particular bill would not cost six
million dollars this bill would allocate
one dollar this bill creates a legal
framework for this plan
we would need to persuade each other and
explain the plan sufficiently to
Citizens and at a further date allocate
funding for it for it to become fully
active so this creates a legal framework
not a cost now I have estimated what
this bill if it were fully utilized by
every candidate in both parties for
executive Council and Governor Mike cost
and the Six Million Dollar estimate is
accurate it's about eight dollars per
voter per election cycle
and
that's what it would cost for a system
of clean elections I wouldn't be
donating to candidates I don't support I
would be funding a clean election system
that's what it would cost to restore
voter confidence in our elections and
for that reason
I'd like to recommend to my colleagues
that you vote ought to pass thank you
genocide and natasto has requested a
roll call as that's officially seconded
it is
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
foreign
on House Bill 324. this is a roll call
vote
chair recognizes representative prude
home O'Brien for a parliamentary inquiry
creates opportunities for fraud
and if I also know that this bill is is
expensive and we do not know the true
costs of what it will be
and lastly and most importantly if I
know that this bill will compel citizens
to financially support campaigns that
they oppose
would I now press the red button and
oppose the motion of ought to pass
care recognize her representative
Muirhead for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know
that the influence of the out-of-state
donor Elite damages confidence in our
elections and disadvantages strong local
candidates with deep roots in the state
and in their communities if I know
that voter owned elections
have been tried in other places and work
if I know that this bill would Empower
New Hampshire voters
and New Hampshire candidates with Broad
and deep support would I press the green
button
to vote Yes ought to pass motion before
us was ought to pass when House Bill 324
this is a roll call vote you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you
opposer press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
thank you
foreign
members president had an opportunity to
vote
house will attend to the state of the
163 voting Aid 200 voting nay the motion
fails
for what reason does a member rise in
expedient to legislate
I move and experience
the motion is inexpedient to legislate
are you ready for the question uh
is
are you ready for the question all those
all those in favor say aye foreign
[Applause]
a division will is called
there was question whether it was yay or
nay
members be in their seats
the question before us
that was a Voice vote that was
undeterminable is if you're in favor of
the itl you vote yay if you're opposed
to vote in a voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
um
. it's how to go through 24.
we've got it
this is house bill 324.
representative Perez
to vote please
the speaker has stated what the bill is
the board does not matter the speaker
has stated 324 was what was on the what
we're taking up thank you
representative Bale
representative Lovett
representative meniere
represent Megan Murray
representative Juris
Representative Vincent
represent Haskins
representative Manos
representative Edgar
present flutier
representative McAleer
represent gretian
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
201 voting yay 163 voting May the i-2
itl motion is a
for what reason does it member rise
thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to make a
motion
I'm sorry I Rise to make a motion okay
State your motion I would like to move
that HB 234 from the science technology
and energy committee be removed from the
table
the motion is in order
which is
I know I'm just standing here
foreign
I need you to look at it
because
[Music]
moving to the table and then some
packages
are failing aside which is
members take your seats
division vote members take your seats
the motion before us is to remove
House Bill 234 from the table this is
going to be a division vote
we're just going to have two pis and
then we'll go right into the boat
chair recognize representative Weber
thank you thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that a member who voted
uh
itl on this motion
which I'm sorry
let me start over
if I know that there is a member who
voted
we had a tie
and that a member who voted on the side
of having the bill fail
would like to reconsider his vote
would I now give him that consideration
to be able to move reconsideration by
removing this bill from the table and
pressing the green button
for a parliamentary inquiry
Mr Speaker if I know
that the purpose of this bill
was to repeal a law that has been in
effect for well over 15 years
and if I also know that doing so would
eliminate
a logical
idea that was put into statutes
representative Rose this is strictly not
on the bill itself on removing it from
the table my apologies Mr Speaker
we need to move on if I know that we
need to move on this afternoon and get
our work done would I leave this bill on
the table by pressing the red button
thank you
the motion before us on house bills
234 is to remove it from the table this
is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for
30 seconds and members should be in
their seats
thank you
representative Hill
representative Balboni
you can't push the button you have to
give me a thumb up or thumb down please
representative Thomas thank you
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to the state
of the vote
179 voting day 182 voting May the motion
fails
committee on it the house will be in
order
committee on Election law to which was
referred House Bill 502 FN relative to
voter affidavit ballots this comes
without recommendation representative
Lane moves ought to pass
the chair recognizes representative
Barry
thank you Mr Speaker
um HB 502
would would return New Hampshire to a
series of Lawless elections
so let me explain to you what we what
you would be voting for if you vote for
HP hb502
you would be voting so that any person
can walk into any polling location
register to vote while presenting
literally nothing not a driver's license
not a student ID not a bill not a text
message nothing
they can go they are then handed a
ballot not a affidavit ballot they are
handed a full ballot that then goes into
the box but wait it actually does more
because it doesn't just repeal affidavit
ballots it actually walks us back
farther and restores the religious uh
picture affidavit which not a single
person the people who opposed it when we
repealed this last year they weren't
able to find a single person with
standing to sue over it that would mean
that somebody can walk into the polling
location present nothing not even have
their picture taken and they are handed
a ballot
it's ridiculous it what it does is it
breeds a lack of faith into our
elections when people do not believe in
the process they don't vote
they are going to get up here and
they're going to tell you this is about
people showing up without ID this is
about people who are not on the poll not
on they are not registered to vote so if
you forget your ID and you're registered
to vote in your town this doesn't affect
you you can still vote everything's fine
this is about people showing up to the
polls on Election Day who are not
registered to vote and not presenting
anything about who they are or where
they live
voter ID and this isn't even voter ID
this is showing something when you're
registering voter ID is overwhelmingly
popular and it's not just overwhelmingly
popular with Republicans it's
overwhelmingly popular with Democrats in
New Hampshire there's been two polls
conducted about this and both times a
majority of Democrats polled supported
showing an ID at the polls stand with
your voters and vote against the ought
to pass motion
chair recognize representative Wayne
thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to speak for
the passage of hb502 the bill will
repeal what we voted into law last year
RSA 659 colon 23A which was passed along
party lines by this house an established
affidavit voting balloting also known as
provisional or challenge ballots it was
passed in the name of election Integrity
as we just heard without pointing to any
evidence of abuse of the election system
and without review the house will be in
order
and without the review of the New
Hampshire Supreme Court or the
attorney's General's office as requested
by the minority party
the existing law effectively removes the
ability of a voter without photo
identification to sign an affidavit at
the voting Place swearing to the voter's
address and identity owners voters
without
photo IDs must return the packet that
they are given and a copy of any
required documentation to the Secretary
of State's office and the provided
Prepaid U.S postal envelope within seven
days of the election in order for their
ballot to be certified
their votes may not count due to the
slowness of the U.S Postal Service or
the inability to retrieve the necessary
documents by the deadline this bill will
return the law to its status prior to
the enactment of sb4 18 last year
in addition to being a thinly veiled
voter suppression effort our existing
law is riddled
is riddled with serious flaws first
whether it violates the New Hampshire
Constitution part 2 article 32 by adding
or subtracting votes after the tally is
made by the moderator on Election night
under existing law affidavit ballots
cannot be finely counted or reported
until 10 days after the election day
provisional accounting as many as tens
of thousands of ballots on election day
just to subtract them
ten days later does not satisfy the
requirement of the ballots are counted
in the same meeting or the same day as
the election they are therefore
inconsistent with part two article 32's
mandate that all ballots be counted on
the day that they are cast this is
currently in court being contested on
this point the law may also violate the
state's newest constitutional provision
part 2 article 2B which says an
individual's right to live free from
governmental intrusion in private or
personal information is natural
essential and inherent provisional
ballots are not secret they are assigned
a number linking them to the voter the
moderator and other voting officials
will be able to see the provisional
ballot linked to the voter secret
ballots or at the heart of our democracy
and our right to privacy
the time frames in the existing law make
it extremely difficult and probably in
some cases impossible to comply with
What's called the uniformed and overseas
citizens absentee voting ballot called
you okava which requires ballots to be
mailed to service members and their
families 45 days prior to the election
because our state primary is so late
this year there's 56 days before the
general election between the primary and
the general election the secretaries of
State's office already has a type time
tight timeline to comply with the
statute
the new law that we enacted last year
makes compliance even more difficult for
the Secretary of State because the
election totals will be recalculated 10
to 14 days after the primary with
potential new winners announced one day
before the yukava deadline for valid for
ballots to be formatted printed and sent
and if a recount is permitted and
requested final primary members will not
be known in time to meet the 45-day
deadline
finally RSA the existing law also
conflicts with RSA 65616 which provides
that there shall be no impression or
Mark to distinguish one general election
ballot from another
the affidavit is marked by the moderator
in some the law we passed last year
imposes unnecessary burdens on Election
administrators and voters it does not
comply with the Constitution and it
flies in the face of Governor sununu's
statements confirming the safety and
reliability of New Hampshire elections
as well as the findings of the Secretary
of State's special committee on voter
confidence it does not comply with
federal law and endangers the right of
military and Military
and their families to vote for these
reasons I urge the members of this house
to repeal the existing law and vote
ought to pass on hb502
I also asked for a division vote Mr
Speaker
Mr Clerk
I asked for a division vote
who
I think
he was representative Perez requests a
roll called vote is that sufficiently
seconded
members take your seats this will be a
division vote
[Music]
we've already had a request and it
failed
be it this will be a division vote
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 502 this will be a division
vote
chair recognizes representative
clearly
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr
turnis to a situation where anyone can
walk into New Hampshire polling station
on election day to register for the
first time and receive a ballot without
any proof whatsoever of their
identification
and if I know
that we have an obligation to our public
our voters our constituents to ensure
that not only do all qualified voters
have the opportunity to cast a ballot
but that also only qualified voters have
the opportunity to cast a ballot
and if I know that this bill if passed
would leave us with no way to know how
many of our voters were qualified
and in addition if I know that this the
current law applies only to those who
show up to a polling station to register
for the first time on Election Day with
no ID
and I know that it has been testified in
committee when SB 418 was in the process
of passing SP 418 that there is more
than adequate time to get ballots out to
yukava voters overseas voters
would I then preserve the integrity and
the accountability
and the trust of our voters in our
election processes by pressing the red
button to vote no on this motion thank
you
chair recognize representative brand new
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know New Hampshire elections are
safe secure and there has been no
evidence of widespread voter fraud
and if I know that the constitutionality
of the provisional ballot law is being
challenged in court and Mr Speaker if I
know Granite Staters including our
overseas service members value their
right to vote and have that vote counted
would I now press the green button to
support the repeal of the unnecessary
and constitutionally questionable
provisional ballot law thank you
the motion before us
is ought to pass on House Bill 502.
this will be a division vote
if you're in favor you will press the
green button if you are opposed to a
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
thank you
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
house will tend to state of the vote
179 voting a 182 voting a
the motion fails for what reason does
the member rise Mr Speaker I would like
to move an expedient to legislate
member makes a motion of inexpeding to
legislate and house bill 502.
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested
I hope everybody is still in their seats
the motion before us is inexperienced to
legislate on House Bill 502.
this is going to be a division vote
if you're in favor you will press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
thank you
the legislature has continued to vote do
not not vote thank you
[Applause]
representative Perez
thank you
representative Ford
where are we 101
how so also be in order
[Music]
the house will turn to the state of the
road
182 to 181 the motion passes the speaker
did vote
[Music]
committee on Election law to which was
referred House Bill 508 FN act relative
to the payment of postage on absentee
ballot return envelopes considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved at its in expedient
to legislate it's in a Robert weary for
the committee
it's in a weary
oh this is
Gia recognizes representative wheeler
wheeler yeah representative wheeler
he's recognized to represent wheeler
between the wheeler you're recognized to
speak
I apologize Mr Speaker I was being
talked to couldn't hear you thank you Mr
Speaker
New Hampshire is a state of many
elections everyone in this building has
to run every two years we have town
meeting annually and as all of you who
have been in Rochester over these last
few weeks know very well we have special
elections and you can bet on it almost
every off here
tens of thousands of Voters in these
elections vote absentee every time as
the Secretary of State Illustrated in
the fiscal note to this legislation an
absentee voting has been a practice
since the Civil War going back to when
soldiers needed to
practice their civil duties their civic
duty on the battlefield while protecting
and defending this country the country
which gave them that civic duty
and it it is quite unfortunate that the
process of absentee voting given its
history and given its long-standing in
the United States has become such a
partisan tool over these last few Cycles
free and fair voting is one of the
Bedrock processes which keeps this
nation's politics vibrant and strong and
the practice of absentee voting ensures
every citizen their right to cast a
ballot for those who they want to
represent them in the halls of
government
House Bill 508 says to a voter who
determines they need to use the absentee
system to perform their civic duty that
their ballot will come with the correct
postage when received the many elections
we have also means many ballots in all
different sizes in all different shapes
and the stamps required to mail out a
ballot in Peterborough might be
different than the stamps required to
mail out a ballot in Windham
which has many more candidates on a
given general election ballot
some ballots being so heavy as to
require multiple stamps there is no
posted standard for our elections
the voters who request an absentee
ballot are people who already have a
tough enough time requesting the ballot
however that however unbelievable that
may be for us able-bodied folks those
same barriers exist for them simply
stepping outside of the house let alone
dealing with the bureaucracy of voting
so when I read the committee report by
my friend from Hudson I cringe a little
bit thinking of my differently abled
brothers and sisters in my community and
throughout this state who know how hard
it is in this day and age to do even the
basic of tasks let alone like I said
vote and again however hard that may be
for us with enough energy to sit here
all day to believe this is the reality
for people in our state
the cost outlined in the committee
report of researching the candidates
Transportation or time taken to place
one's vote are all something that
someone who's voting absentee also must
incur and I do not purport to believe
that those personal costs should not be
when an individual has incurred the cost
of getting out of the house driving to
their Town Clerk and requesting an
absentee ballot they should be treated
no differently than the person who takes
the time on Election Day to get out of
their house drive to the polling place
and vote
to pay a dollar to the feds to put your
ballot in the accounting machine at your
polling place no you do not and that
would be absolutely ridiculous if you
did so why should a voter who has to pay
who has to use an absentee ballot have
to pay a dollar to the feds to have that
ballot counted via the mail
what do we pay taxes for
the status quo has voters in two classes
those who put their ballot in the
machine for no cost and those who mail
out their ballot with a postage cost to
the federal government
contrary to what my friend from Hudson
said in the committee report this
legislation takes us another step
forward in breaking up the status quo of
having two different classes of Voters
and ensuring the rights of every citizen
are upheld as by we those who swore to
do so
now I wish I could claim I had some
genius original idea here but
unfortunately for me and my ego I did
not this is a proposal which has been
implemented in 19 States
and counting on a bipartisan basis not
just scary liberal states like
Washington Rhode Island Maryland and
Massachusetts but ruby red States like
West Virginia Idaho and Missouri Iowa as
well have also implemented similar
programs this is a common sense proposal
which guarantees no one is paying a
dollar to the feds once they've made the
journey to vote and that no one's ballot
gets bounced back for something as silly
as it being too heavy
everyone at some point or another may
have to use an absentee ballot and we
pay taxes for the roads not because
everyone will use them
but because everyone can use them same
can be said for our schools and so many
other public institutions the postage on
an absentee ballot isn't anywhere near
as poor important as the roads or our
schools and I won't claim it to be
but voting is still a public right
and once an absentee ballot is filled
out it should be received without paying
a dollar to the feds when you mail it
we've paid our taxes and those taxes
should be used to guarantee each right
and service is properly and effectively
funded including something as small as a
postage on yours or another person's
absentee ballot so join me in voting
against this committee report so we can
be the 20th state to realize this
impactful but Small Change is the right
way to move forward as a state thank you
very much there's a member of yield the
questions
those are memory yield to questions
remember yields
sorry to my friends
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
representative for taking my question
would it be a logical extension of this
program to offer mileage to voters who
drive to the polls no wouldn't as I said
in my speech someone who drives to the
town clerk or is as the same as someone
who drives to the polling place so we
wouldn't pay for you to go to the
polling place this is about once you
have requested a ballot that ballot
should come with the necessary things
that's needed to have that ballot
counted I'm not talking about going to
the polling place going to the polling
place as I said here should still have
some cost personal costs just as going
to the grocery store does
motion before us is inexperiential
legislator in House Bill 508 share
recognized representative weary
thank you I will not be as eloquent as
my colleague from Peterborough but I
will be brief
um Point number one
um this asks for a hundred thousand
annually for prepaid postage on absentee
ballot return envelopes
inherent with the great privilege to
vote is an intrinsic cost to vote so
whether it's time transportation or
postage voters bear some nominal cost
by spending a hundred thousand annually
for prepaid postage on absentee ballot
return envelopes this bill would create
two classes of Voters the reimburse
voter and the unpaid unreimbursed voter
if one goes down the reimbursement
Rabbit Hole where would it end should
pen or ink or mileage be reimbursed
should the postage for the absentee
ballot request be reimbursed when does
reimbursement end
how much of the annual cost will be
wasted because of unused prepaid
envelopes
finally Point number six
no evidence was provided by the sponsors
as to the extent of this alleged issue
at a hundred thousand annually perhaps
this bill is a massive solution trying
to fix a problem that is really less
than the size of a proverbial postage
stamp
please vote to support the itl for House
Bill 508
the motion before us is inexped into
legislative and house bill 508.
a division vote has been requested
members take your seats
the motion before us
is inexped into legislate and House Bill
508 this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative Heath Howard
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that it is that ensuring
election integrity means that election
officials receive absentee ballots in a
timely and secure Manner and if I know
that this bill is eliminating another
fee associated with voting
and if I know that this is a low-cost
measure to prevent potential obstacles
when voting that 19 other states as well
as Washington DC have approved
and if I know that this puts the tax
burden on the state rather than the
individual
uh then I would suggest that you join me
in pressing the red button so another
motion could be made thank you
Jr recognizes representative Kennedy for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker what I notice is
that the the points that I was going to
make have already been made the
Parliamentary inquiry
sorry yeah yeah okay if I
hurt to favor absentee voters by having
the state pay their postage
would I press the green button on itl
and on House Bill 508. thanks Mr Speaker
the motion before us is any speeding to
legislate on House Bill 508 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if your opposal
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
also attend to stay to the vote
189 voting a 172 voting a committee
report is adopted
committee on the environment and
agriculture to which was referred House
Bill 300 FN enact prohibiting the
disposal of certain food waste
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment a recommendation
that the bill ought to password
Amendment Senator Reagan Murray for the
committee the amendment is zero one six
nine H printed in house record 11 page
38 39.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
I was supposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is the
ought to password Amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye as opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committed
report is adopted and is going to
finance
committee on environment and agriculture
to which was referred House Bill 462 FNA
enact making an appropriation to the
solid waste management fund and
targeting food waste reduction and
diversion considered the same with
Report with the same with the following
Amendment and recommendations Bill ought
to pass with Amendment representative
Judy Aaron for the committee amendment
is zero one five nine H printed in house
record 11 page 41. are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say aye
that was supposedly the eyes have it
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
that was opposed nay your eyes have it
and the committee report is adopted and
it is heading to finance
committee on environment and agriculture
to which was referred House Bill 494
refn a neck relative to fees collected
under the New Hampshire fertilizer law
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass said to Peter Bix
before the committee are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
you guys have it in the committee report
is adopted and it's going two ways and
means
majority of the committee on executive
departments and administration to which
was referred House Bill 341 FN enact
establishing licensure firm massage
establishments have been considered the
same report the same falling resolution
resolved that is inexpeding to legislate
Senate Matthew from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same to be an unable to
agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass Senator Jesse Grody for the
majority minority of the committee
a chair recognizes representative grody
thank you Mr Speaker House Bill 4th 341
is the policy bill that establishes a
licensure for massage establishments
new to New Hampshire in that we have
many establishments that are licensed
such as salons work sites Bank
barbers
estheticians cosmetologists
and electrologists
so what does that mean
in oplc there are three divisions
there's the um
investigative division there's the
compliance Division and there's the
disciplinary division
so what a massage establishment license
does is allows oplc
to check for compliance
to the rules of that board
and
so this means that after this bill were
to pass
there would have to be rules established
and these rules are done in compliance
with the board and oplc
so I wanted to go through this example
with you because it's just not passing a
bill it means establishing rules that
are
that are decided by the board and the
agency which is oplc and then approved
by gel car I think you heard
representative McGuire mention gel car a
little earlier
so I hope that you will overturn the itl
by voting red so that a better motion
another motion can be made thank you
chair recognize Senator Natasha
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker this bill establishes yet
another licensed businesses will have to
comply with
this license is another set of paperwork
we have to burden our already licensed
massage providers with this licensing
will allow oplc inspectors to inspect
the premises of these businesses
creating a potential Fourth Amendment
violations on the par on the part of the
state being that the Fourth Amendment of
the Constitution uh protects the right
of the people to be secure in their
papers and effects and protects them
from warrantless searches
Additionally the aim of this bill was to
uh in part is to reduce sex trafficking
in the state by targeting the massage
establishments this will have little or
no effect because any illegal businesses
of this kind will Rebrand retool or
simply not comply with a statue that
requires periodic inspections especially
when uncompliance only carries a
misdemeanor charge
this will give more work to oplc and it
is unwise to put oplc inspectors in a
situation where they could be
investigating these kind of crimes and
should be reserved for law enforcement
ask you to support the committee
recommendation thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpected to
legislative and house bill 341.
representative sentence though requests
the roll call is that sufficiently
seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded
it'll be a division vote
members take your seat this will be a
division vote
the motion before us is a majority
committee report of index fitting to
legislate in House Bill 341 this is
going to be a division vote Cher
recognizes representative bordes for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know this is a common sense bill that
will simply give licenses and an
oversight to massage parlies just like
all barber shops and other stuff and if
I know law enforcement
says a lot of sex trafficking happens
through these massage policies why vote
against this itl motion thank you
do I recognize the representative Carol
McGuire for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill is an attempt
to solve a criminal Problem by
a regulatory method of and it would send
the
inspectors of the oplc
to to investigate serious and violent
crimes
and if I know that this would charge the
well-behaved and legitimate businesses
in order to help law enforcement deal
with the illegitimate ones what I
realize that it is an inappropriate
method to solve a problem and vote in
favor of the committee recommendation
press the green button
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexped into
legislator in house bill 341. this is a
division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you approach you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
foreign
Kelly
wall members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
say to the vote
184 voting a 171 voting a committee
report is adopted
committee on executive departments and
administration to which was referred
House Bill 620 FN
establishing a department of early
childhood education and relative to a
pre-kindergarten pilot program this bill
comes to us without recommendation
representative Grody moves ought to pass
and offers Amendment
0-376h printed in house record 11 page
chair recognize representative grody
on the amendment
thank you how's the amendment to hum
House Bill 620 changes the bill from a
department of early childhood education
to a division of early childhood
education as part of the Department of
Education this was done to incorporate
the cost of this
pilot program into the division the
department of education's budget and at
the request of the Department of
Education
so I hope that you'll vote in favor of
the amendment thank you
the motion before us
is the amendment to house bill 620.
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted
the motion before us now was ought to
pass as amended the chair recognizes
representative Tony Lucas
thank you thank you Mr chair uh
speaker sorry wrong environment
um as mentioned the original bill would
have stood up a whole new department for
a pilot program and without that the
bill probably would have gone to the
education committee which would have
been the appropriate place to vet
something like this
what this bill would do is put in place
a three-year pilot program
for funding a Pre-K you know
pre-kindergarten education program
and while there are studies that show
Pre-K education has positive results
there are actually many others including
quite good ones that shows results
ranging from no benefits to actually uh
uh harmful results the only randomized
controlled trial of a Statewide pre-k
program showed there was Improvement
after the first year
after the third grade Pre-K children did
a little worse than the controls and
after sixth grade Pre-K children did
worse on all areas Math Science and
reading and that was actually done by a
Vanderbilt University
there's been no evidence of improvement
in National assessment of educational
progress the knee app scores for
children have taken Pre-K versus those
who have not been in pre-K school and as
I said there were studies done by
Vanderbilt also Harvard University and
one in Germany that shows similar
results
the other issue is a three-year pilot is
too short there may be some improvement
over the short term but the you know
lack of improvement or potentially worse
can show up later and that's what some
of the studies showed so the risk is is
that we run this pilot program are
convinced that it actually is benefiting
children when in fact it may not in the
longer run
and that's that's a problem and so we
should not go down this path please
support itl or oppose in this case
otpa on House Bill 620 thank you
I recognize representative Heath
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise today in support of House Bill
620 as amended 50 years of research
attest to the fact that vital learning
happens before the age of five New
Hampshire has a child care crisis
any of you young mothers know what it's
like
I can remember what it was like when my
children were little and then my my
children went and saw it
quality daycare which wasn't always
available
and there's an urgent need for our state
to deliver early learning resources
early care and education are a critical
resource for young children and working
families and allows parents to remain in
the workforce while providing a healthy
learning environment for their children
to ensure that all children reach their
potential we must reimagine public
education as a system that begins not in
kindergarten but with high quality
pre-kindergarten that demonstrates and
acknowledges the value of high excuse me
the value of early learning
44 States 44 States currently offer
state-funded Early Childhood programming
by by voting yes on HB 620 New Hampshire
would be the 45th
HB 620 creates an early childhood
division in the New Hampshire Department
of Education with appropriate
authorization and employees and early
childhood director to coordinate and
facilitate necessary Communications with
the division of Health and Human
Services and all programs that serve
children the bill also authorizes the
department to design create and
administer a three-year high-quality
community-based mixed delivery public
pre-kindergarten pilot program
a mixed delivery model means the
different types of high quality Early
Education providers May participate in
the pilot program including public and
non-public schools and community-based
programs such as Head Start and licensed
child care providers at the end of the
pilot program a report will be submitted
to the governor and general court that
reports on
I'm sorry progress made
in communities during the duration of
the pilot with details of how these
programs have benefited the pilot
communities including family engagement
student performance and Effectiveness
New Hampshire is the second oldest state
and we need to attract young families to
live and work in our state HB 620
presents an opportunity for New
Hampshire to invest in its younger
youngest members
Elevate the importance of early learning
and deliver a much needed system of
learning please vote Yes on HB 620 so
the bill can go forward to the finance
committee thank you very much
motion before us has ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 620. son of
Senator natasto has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded members will
take their seats this will be a roll
call vote
the motion before us is ought to pass as
a man did on House Bill 620.
this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes
representative Carol McGuire for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr secure if I know that this
bill
conflates child care with education
and it this bill also attempts to use
mostly one-time money to establish a
permanent
Department org division
of this of the state government
and if I know that the pilot program is
too short to be effective
and that
there are it also violates local control
by establishing a state program for what
should be local what I
push the red button and oppose ought to
pass
chair recognizes representative Wilhelm
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that the New
Hampshire Department of Education has
expressed support for establishing a
division of early learning and a limited
three-year Pre-K pilot program
and Mr Speaker if I know that research
shows that children's participation in
high quality early childhood education
programs enhances their development
reduces achievement gaps at kindergarten
entry and can have long-term benefits
for children's educational trajectories
and Mr Speaker if I further know that
high quality community-based mixed
delivery public Pre-K funded through the
Department of Education and administered
by its division of early learning would
improve educational outcomes for New
Hampshire students than would I now push
the green button to prepare Granite
State kiddos for Effective K-12 learning
and route to meaningful citizenship and
productive careers in our 21st century
economy goals that I know we all share
thank you Mr Speaker
motion before us is ought to pass as
amended and house bill 620. this is a
roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed you'll
press the red button Pony stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend a
state of the vote
183 voting a 174 voting a
commit a report of water passes adopted
and it is on its way to finance
we're not one that bill is removed from
consent
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 102 local an act
requiring high schools to include
instruction on the nature and history of
Communism having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpected to
legislate Senator Felicia leak is for
the committee
for what reason does a member rise I
stand to make a motion please the house
will be in order
the motion to table please
motion is in order
there's an Awad moves the table house
bill 102.
a division has been requested members
will take their seats
okay
thank you
parliamentary no I'm not going to do
this I want to go home
the motion before us is to table house
bill 102. this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative
Campbell's for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
if I know that my family and I escaped
from communist Cuba
because we lost everything we owned
including our personal rights
and if I know
that communism is inherently evil
that the lack of knowledge on the
subject of Communism will lead to the
propagation
of that evil system of government
than what I now pressed vote no and
press the red button thank you Mr
Speaker
do you recognize representative Ladd for
parliamentary inquiry
speaker
if I know this bill requires
for a high school student to graduate
from high school to have a one-hour
class on communism
or the class may be embedded within some
other class
and if I know that for one hour of
instruction
without any kind of guidelines what that
con instruction on communism may be
you could have things taught that maybe
shouldn't be taught
and if I know that when we adopt these
types of standards
and requirements for graduation from a
high school we're talking in minimum
standards for public school approval
would I then press the green button
with the hope that any bill that comes
forward in the future on this can be
more thoroughly explained and more work
put into it so we know where we're going
thank you
the motion before us is the table house
bill 102. this is
we're in the voting mode this is a
division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
representative
[Music]
representative Hawaii
members president an opportunity to vote
house will attend this state of the vote
314-148
44 voting a house bill 102 is laid on
the table
committee on Election law to which was
referred House Bill 482 FN enact
requiring the use of ballots
with embedded Security traceability in
relative to the chain of custody for
ballast casts and elections considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpeding to legislate representative
Ralph bone for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
as opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
committee on Election law to which was
referred House Bill 599 FN enact
relatively requiring an audit of the
November 2022 election results having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpected to legislate
representative Clayton wood for the
committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
we'll suppose nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
committee on Judiciary to which was
referred House Bill 340 FN act relative
to a transfer of residential property of
a considered the same report the same
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpediate to legislate Senator
Scott Wallace for the committee
chair recognizes representative Newell
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise today on behalf to speak on
behalf of 340.
the save our homes Act
in the summer of 2021 the Fox News
YouTube channel posted a clip of their
host Tucker Carlson talking about a
little known but very impactful
Corporation BlackRock
Tucker a man I disagree with 99.9 of the
time spoke about how BlackRock is slowly
but surely gobbling up homes in many
parts of America by outbidding families
looking to buy them
why would a venture capitalist Capital
firm offer two hundred thousand dollars
over asking price for homes guaranteeing
they'll win the bid well once they own
the home they can rent it forever making
far more in profits and of course they
do
according to an article posted in the
Atlantic a quarter of all single-family
home sales went to some form of
corporate investor
all told nearly a third of American
house sales last year went to people who
had absolutely no intention of living in
them
in fact corporate conglomerates like
BlackRock are investing heavily in our
homes Holmes once passed down over
Generations are sold at a rate
commensurate to the living standard in
that locality now overbid by hundreds of
thousands of dollars shutting out folks
like you and I from the running
these properties will be rented out over
years their impact on the housing market
disconnected completely from the
localities in which they sit
but there's something else that we're
giving away by allowing these massive
corporate conglomerates to buy up all of
America's homes and rent them until the
end of time the American dream
for the last several Generations
Americans have relied on single-family
homes to build a nest egg for retirement
they allow you to build equity they're a
place to raise a family they allow your
kids to stay in the same community
long enough to make friends get involved
with their local community center and
save them the experience of moving every
year as often happens with folks who
live in apartments
they provide families stability homes
build community
ask your kids or grandkids
if uh if they or people their age think
that home ownership will be in their
grasp
the answer you're probably going to get
is no
this is a tragedy and the wealthiest
nation in the world where we are blessed
by abundance and opportunity but it's
our responsibility to defend that
opportunity
that's why I'm supporting the save our
homes act the bill is simple straight
from the bill real estate on which
single-family housing including
single-family housing with one or more
accessory dwelling units on it on the
same parcel of land or multi-family
housing is located may only be acquired
in whole or in part by natural persons
subject to the following exceptions
so in basic terms this bill requires
single-family homes to be sold to a real
living breathing person
not a venture capital firm not a venture
capital firm putting on the Groucho Marx
disguise and pretending to be an LLC
nothing but a natural person
there's a grandfathering exception
provided that the next buyer is a
natural person there's a development
exception provided that the property is
sold to a natural person within two
years and there's a clarification that
this will have no impact on mortgages
the opposition of this bill seems to
center around the constitutionality
concerns and not only could I not agree
less about those concerns but they're
also not ours to decide the power of
judicial review rests
solely in the courts
this may be the general court but it's
not the court court
but let's discuss the concerns all the
same I would gather the concern center
around corporate personhood
and the idea that corporations are
people
setting aside setting that aside for
just a moment
in our Statute in New Hampshire we
already have laws on the books that have
different punishments for corporations
and people because of course we do in
New Hampshire stealing a Lobster Pot is
a mere violation if you're a natural
person but a crime if done by a
corporate entity what about voting your
town voter checklist likely doesn't have
your local Dunkin Donuts franchise shop
on its rolls
there are some things afforded to people
not afforded corporations
and buying a single-family home to raise
a family
ought to be one of them
I believe it's important to keep family
homes for families
I believe that passing this law will
help reduce and eliminate homelessness
in our time
I will not allow soulless conglomerate
corporations to deny anyone the American
dream
I feel that now is the time to do this
there were another crash like the 2008
housing crash Banks would be desperate
to make up their money
making it extremely convenient for
companies like BlackRock to swoop in
overbid take the homes and rent them
forever
I know full well that the forces of the
privileged flu few excuse me
it's gonna come out privileged few and
the special interests will come out in
full force against this good legislation
to paraphrase president uh Franklin
Roosevelt they may be unanimous in their
hate for this bill but I welcome that
hatred
by passing this law today and
overturning the itl we will be saying
loudly and firmly that we prioritize
real people over corporations and we
believe that in in a New Hampshire and
in America where home ownership is a
reality
and the American dream May so endure for
the Next Generation the
and I would like a division vote please
the jail recognizes representative
Wallace
thank you Mr Speaker colleagues House
Bill 340 would seek to restrict the
acquisition of single and multi-family
properties to Natural persons with
certain exceptions
the bill would require a non-natural
person that acquires single or
multi-family property within one of the
specified exceptions to register and
file reports with the Secretary of State
this filing is already in place in the
form of an annual report which is
required to be filed for all types of
entities already and is currently the
law
it's for failures to file the additional
new annual report and comply with the
provisions in this extreme proposal
would generate violation referrals to
the Attorney General's office for
enforcement which ultimately could
result in The uncompensated Taking of
private property and its transferred to
the municipality in which it's located
proposed new filing would be an
unnecessary burden on property owners
and add unneeded burden to the Secretary
of State's corporate division
with its unanimous bipartisan 20 to
nothing vote this proposal was itl out
of committee and colleagues I ask that
you support the committee's sensible
well-informed recommendation of
inexpedient to legislate thank you
represent
representative representative Murray has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
I'm only counting people that are in
their seats
it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate and House Bill 340
the house will be in order
we're almost done
this is a roll call vote
care recognize Alessandra Murray for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that home
ownership is one of the cornerstones of
the American dream and if I know that
corporate conglomerates like BlackRock
and other financial institutions are
buying up homes across New Hampshire to
rent them in perpetuity pricing families
out of the market and creating false
inflation in the market and if I know
that before us here today is a bill that
bans corporations from stealing homes
from families while keeping in place all
the exceptions necessary to ensure the
continuity of trusts mortgages and
renovations
and lastly if I know if we don't take
action now to save Homes corporate
ownership of the housing market will
only grow into another 2008 scenario
running the risk of vanquishing the
Eternal Light Of Hope for a better
future for your family and America would
I now push the red button to save our
homes and the American Dreams in 2023.
thank you Mr Speaker do you recognize
representative Wallace for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that thousands of New Hampshire
Property Owners hold single and
multi-family Residential Properties and
llc's llps IRS subchapter S and C
corporations and Mr Speaker if I know
that non-compliance with or violation of
the provision set forth in House Bill
340 could ultimately result in a
transferral of said property to the
political subdivision in which it's
located by an uncompensated taking the
equivalent of a 100 tax on an asset that
could be worth millions for a violation
of the statute and Mr Speaker if I know
the taxation is theft and finally Mr
Speaker if I know that the sentence
and finally Mr Speaker if I know the
sensible and well-informed members of
the House Judiciary Committee found this
bill in expedient to legislate in a
unanimous bipartisan vote what an out
press the green button to support the
committee's recommendation
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate
on House Bill 340. this is a roll call
vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you approach or press
the red button warning stations are open
for 30 seconds
thank you
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
the vote
273 voting yay 78 voting a committee
report is adopted Senator Wilhelm
declared a conflict of interest and did
not participate
committee on state and federal relations
and Veterans Affairs to which was
referred HCI 3 act relative to affirming
States Powers over the Federal
Constitution considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
version of David Lundgren for the
committee
for what reason does a member rise Mr
Speaker I moved to table
it is a proper motion
a motion before us is the table
somebody
the motion before us is the table HC art
hcr3
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it in the tabling motion
on hcr3 passes
do you recognize the member from Auburn
representative Osborne for the third
weed emotion I think he resolved that
the house now adjourned from the early
session that the business of the late
session be in order at the present time
that the reading of bills be by title
only and resolutions by caption only and
that all bills ordered a third reading
be read a third time by this resolution
and that all titles of bills be the same
as adopted and that they be passed at
the present time and when the house
adjourns today at B to meet at the call
of the chair
question is
question is on the third reading motion
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
as opposed nay the eyes have it and the
motion is adopted house will attend to
announcements
please can everybody just sit in their
seats for a couple of minutes so they
can hear the announcements in case it
affects you
uh representative McGuire I'm assuming
it's Carol McGuire
thank you Mr Speaker the DNA pension
subcommittee will be meeting tomorrow
morning at 9 30 on House Bill 436 thank
you
care organizers representative Wayne
McDonald
thank you Mr Speaker and tomorrow
afternoon executive the health and human
services and elderly Affairs committee
will be taking up a number of bills in
executive session in addition to those
listed in the calendar will also be
considering House Bill 614 an amendment
thank you
chair recognize representative Wyler
thank you Mr Speaker members there have
been some confusing messages out today
tomorrow at 10 o'clock and finance
committee 210 to 11 the governor will be
presenting the budget to the committee
there may be a chance to ask questions
and I'm told it will be on the TV so
you'll be able to watch it
for Thursday night
brother Master Mason's here you are
invited to the the Ironworks Road
Masonic building for a dinner at 5 30
for Master Masons only on the Ironworks
Road if you don't know where it is come
and see me thank you
do you recognize representative Osborne
free lunch
the New Hampshire retail association
invites you to their annual meeting at
the Concord Holiday Inn this Thursday 11
A.M to 1 p.m where they will be
presenting their annual retailer of the
Year award legislator of the Year award
and law enforcement partner of the Year
Lord award and lunch will be provided
gee I recognize the clerk thank you Mr
Speaker just a couple of quick
announcements please remove all the
items from your seat Pockets take them
with you please dispose of them in the
trash cans or the recycling bins not on
the floors and also if you could please
empty out your mailboxes in the ante
room thank you
the house will attend a request for
United is consent
um representative shuitt
I Rise to celebrate the accomplishments
of some amazing women
for those of you who watched The Puppy
Bowl on Sunday I would like you to know
that history was made over at Super Bowl
57 as an all-female flight crew
performed the traditional flyover to
commemorate the 50th anniversary of
women flying for the U.S Navy
four aircraft flying over the stadium in
Glendale Arizona were an EA 18g Growler
piloted by Lieutenant Margaret Dente of
North Salem New York with Lieutenant
Lindsey Evans from Palmdale California
the electronic weapons officer in the
back seat
a fifth generation
f-35c lightning II with lieutenant
suzelle Thomas of Birmingham Alabama and
Lieutenant Jacqueline Drew of Waltham
Massachusetts
and two super Hornets one piloted by
Lieutenant Ariel ash from Abilene Texas
with Lieutenant sarri Marino Weapons
Systems officer of Birmingham Alabama
the other with Lieutenant Katie
Perkowski of Albuquerque New Mexico and
Lieutenant Naomi ingali Weapons Systems
officer of Springfield Virginia
in addition to the officer air Crews the
majority of the enlisted Logistics
maintenance and Grand Cru supporting the
flyover were also women from the U.S
Navy
as with all traditional flyovers the
four aircraft Flew Over the stadium in a
diamond formation perfectly timing their
appearance to coincide with the final
notes of the national anthem
mission accomplished
thank you all for allowing me to
commemorate this moment in history today
I recognize representative Perez
thank you Mr Speaker and members
today I want to take a moment to say
thank you everyone who supported
our brothers and sisters from Puerto
Rico supporting H.R 13 resolution give
us a third determination to my brothers
and sisters Puerto Rico thank you so
much for doing that my appreciation was
for all the community leaders who's been
working really hard to pass this
especially for Carlos Cardona he's a
community leader who's been working
really really hard to try to introduce
this and try to pass it from the bottom
of my heart thank you thank you thank
you so much for the respect from my
brothers and sisters from Puerto Rico
foreign
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I'd like to move that the
previous two speakers remarks be
included in the permanent Journal
without objection chair recognized
representative selig
Lauren selig from Durham and I just
would ask the members who are still here
and I thank you for waiting to join me
in a moment of silence to honor the
memory of the students whose lives were
lost at Marjory Stoneman Douglas five
years ago today and last night at
Michigan State University
thank you
representative Osborne moved that the
house standing recess for the purposes
or introduction of bills and Road build
amendments and Road build reports and
receiving messages you're ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it and
the emotion is adopted